directed by christopher nolan
interstellar is a fantastic tale of time
space and love but if you got a bit lost
in the final act of the film we wouldn't
blame you so let's do our best to walk
through the bizarre mind-bending ending
of
interstellar life on earth isn't great
in interstellar massive dust storms are
tearing up the planet crops are failing
and soon humanity will cease to exist
looking for answers nasa turns to the
skies hoping for some kind of insight
okay
now you need to tell me what your plan
is to save the world
as we learn at the beginning of the film
a group of 12 scientists traveled
through a mysterious wormhole that
appeared near saturn to see if the 12
planets on the other side could sustain
human life a few years later the
endurance and its crew including matthew
mcconaughey's cooper and anne hathaway's
brand are going to visit the three most
promising planets in the hopes of
colonizing one when they arrive on dr
mann's planet the heroic scientist
assures them this icy cold spot is the
perfect place for humans to live
our world
is cold
stark
but undeniably beautiful
unfortunately it's soon all revealed to
be a ruse although each of the original
12 scientists knew their trip was one
way man admits he never fully considered
the possibility that his planet would be
uninhabitable and that he might die
alone although he resisted the urge for
years he eventually falsified his survey
data to coax another team to travel to
his planet intending to use the
endurance to escape at this point man is
so desperate to leave that he'll do
anything even kill paranoid that the
endurance crew won't go along with his
plan once they learn what he's done man
attempts to kill cooper so he can make
his getaway
back on earth cooper's now grown
children find themselves at odds his
daughter murph played by jessica
chastain has realized the surface of our
planet has become uninhabitable so
naturally she's trying to persuade her
brother tom to bring his family to the
secret nasa facility where she's been
working on the gravitational equation
that would allow humanity to escape into
space and mass but despite murph's
warnings tom refuses to abandon the
farmhouse where they grew up after
cooper left them in their grandfather's
care when they were children never to be
heard from again tom lost all faith in
nasa's ability to help them
that didn't raise you to be this dumb
tom dad didn't raise me grandpa did and
he's buried out back with mom and jesse
convinced her brother is making a
terrible mistake murph sets fire to
tom's cornfields knowing that since tom
relies on his crops for survival he'll
be forced to drive out to try to
extinguish the blaze that buys murph
enough time to return to the house and
evacuate tom's wife and son likely in
the hopes that once tom realizes his
family has gone to the nasa facility
they'll have no choice but to join them
hey desperate times call for desperate
measures
without enough fuel to either return to
earth or travel to the third potentially
habitable planet cooper proposes to use
the gravity of the black hole gargantua
to execute a slingshot maneuver which
would send the endurance off with enough
inertia to reach the planet dr edmunds
would send to assess however every time
the endurance crew approaches the black
hole its gravitational field distorts
their perception of time due to
relativity meaning what they experience
is only minutes passes as years for
anyone outside gargantua's gravity every
hour we spend on that planet will be
seven years back on earth by executing
cooper's slingshot maneuver he and brand
will experience time slippage of 51
years they both realize this means
cooper will have to give up hope of ever
seeing his children back on earth as
they will likely have died of old age by
the time the endurance exits gargantua's
gravity still cooper knows that his plan
is humanity's last chance for survival
adding even more drama to cooper's
decision is man's earlier speech about
the moment humans experience before
death according to man as our brains
grasp at survival we'll experience a
vision of the thing we most desire to
see again man speculates that cooper's
final image will be of his children
since they're his reason for living at
the moment of death your mind's gonna
push a little bit harder to survive
for them
by giving up hopes of seeing his
children again cooper is prioritizing
the future of humanity over his own
motivations for survival
with its depleted fuel supplies
endurance must decrease its weight to
pull free of gargantua's gravity after
completing cooper's slingshot maneuver
before beginning the maneuver cooper
decides the shuttle holding tars will
detach and drop into the black hole in
addition to relieving the endurance of
the shuttle's weight cooper hopes that
tars can collect the quantum data from
inside the singularity that nasa
scientists on earth need to complete the
gravitational equation that will allow
humanity to leave while odds are slim
that tars will be able to transmit this
data back to earth cooper is determined
to at least try since it's his
children's last hope of survival however
cooper doesn't tell brand that losing
tar's shuttle won't account for a big
enough drop in weight in fact an
additional shuttle has to detach in
order for the endurance to escape cooper
decides that he should bite the
proverbial bullet leaving bran to
continue on to edmund's planet and
restart the human race he doesn't tell
brand until the last moment because he
knows she would argue with his decision
but even without the possibility of
seeing his children again cooper is at
peace with his probable death
after falling into the black hole cooper
continues to record what he's seeing and
transmits it back to tars hoping the
additional data might help scientists
back on earth although he expects to
eventually get crushed by gargantua's
gravity cooper is miraculously spared
once his shuttle is ripped apart and
that's when things get crazy after
surviving the wild ride cooper gets
transported to an infinite
interdimensional library that allows him
to look back into different moments in
his daughter's childhood bedroom
including the day he left for his
mission on the endurance
if you're leaving just go
don't go don't go you idiot
tarz determines that they made it
through gargantua alive because they
were protected by them the mysterious
beings who constructed the wormhole in
the first place since the beginning of
the film who they are has been a mystery
while nasa realized the wormhole was
artificially constructed by some sort of
advanced intelligent beings they didn't
have any information about them beyond
the assumption that they must be
benevolent
tarz deduces they also must have built
this library to help cooper understand
their five-dimensional reality and sure
it's confusing but it's also nice to
have other worldly beings on your side
although the library where they bring
cooper seems to go on forever every part
of this room serves as a window into the
exact same place his daughter murph's
childhood bedroom at first cooper seems
to think he's been brought to her
because of his own desire to see her
again but tarz helps him understand they
have constructed this three-dimensional
reality for cooper allowing him to
access all five dimensions in a way he
can understand why they want to help us
huh i don't know but they constructed
this three-dimensional space inside
their five-dimensional reality to allow
you to understand it together tars and
cooper figure out that through the
library cooper is able to physically
influence different points in space-time
by using gravity to move things as time
and gravity are the fourth and fifth
dimensions that exist in their reality
but what's the point of all this cooper
deduces that he's been brought here to
send a message back through time using
gravity and that murph has to be the one
to receive it cooper realizes that while
he thought they were fixated on him he's
not actually the one who's most
important to saving humanity murph is
the library exists to ensure that cooper
will be able to deliver his daughter the
information she needs right when she
needs it
after cooper finds himself stuck in the
library he realizes he's supposed to
pass along the quantum data that tarz
collected from inside gargantua the
information the robot gathered from
inside the black hole will help murph
save mankind and cooper is the
interdimensional messenger selected by
the same mysterious forces that
constructed this library and created the
wormhole near saturn
but something sent you here they chose
you
or who's they
and once cooper understands his new
purpose he realizes the creatures who've
been assisting humanity aren't
extraterrestrial at all
they didn't bring us here at all
brought ourselves
as it turns out at some point in the
future humanity will advance to a place
where we can navigate through all five
dimensions it's these future humans who
used gravity to create the wormhole that
allowed nasa to send scientists to
explore the 12 planets in the first
place these future humans are also the
ones who protected cooper from the
effects of gargantua just as cooper is
able to use the library to influence
events that for him already happened the
humans of the future have been using
their understanding of time and gravity
to ensure their own survival by
assisting cooper murph nasa and the
other humans of their past
after realizing why the library exists
and that they want cooper to give murph
the quantum data she needs to save the
world tarz asks how cooper plans to
communicate such complex information
from another dimension i love tara's
love
it's just like grand said my connection
with murph it is quantifiable it's the
key
the robot doesn't understand but cooper
explains that he can trust his love for
his daughter to guide him to exactly
where he needs to be as brand explained
earlier in the film love is the only
thing that transcends all dimensions
including time and space cooper decides
to code the quantum data into the second
hand of the watch he gave murph before
he left assuring tars that she will one
day return for it when tarz asks how
cooper can be sure he responds
because i gave it to her
he's confident that her love for him
will lead her to where she needs to go
just as his love led him back to her
sure enough as all this is happening the
adult murph has indeed returned to her
childhood bedroom drawn by an unseen
force she suddenly understands the ghost
from earlier in the film the entity
trying to contact her with dust patterns
on her bedroom floor was actually her
father reminded of her love for him she
finds the watch and voila things are
suddenly starting to look up for
humanity
with the planet dying humans have to
evacuate the place fast but to solve the
gravitational equation that allows
humanity to escape from the tethers of
earth you need quantum data gathered
from inside a black hole the equation
couldn't reconcile relativity with
quantum mechanics you need more more
more what more data you need to see into
a black hole
thinking that collecting such data is
impossible murph believes the people of
earth are doomed and that her father has
abandoned her however once she realizes
that cooper was her childhood ghost and
that he's given her the data she needs
through the watch she's able to solve
the equation ensuring humanity's
survival once cooper passes along the
quantum data the library tesseract
begins to collapse having served its
purpose cooper loses consciousness and
he later wakes up on a space habitat
orbiting saturn just as they brought
cooper to a library and allowed him to
communicate with his daughter and save
humanity they also brought him back to
safety once he was finished with his
mission only instead of earth he's now
on a gigantic colony floating through
space
thanks to merff's calculations and the
data acquired from the black hole humans
were finally able to leave earth and
mass and now they're spread out over
several different space habitats and
it's all thanks to those mysterious
forces who helped cooper in the library
and made sure people would find him once
it was time for the library to close
due to the time slippage that bran
warned about before executing the
slingshot maneuver around gargantua at
least 51 years have passed for the
people of earth but it's only been hours
for cooper by the time he makes it to
the space habitat known as cooper
station his daughter murph whom he last
saw as a little girl is an old woman on
the verge of death on the flip side
cooper appears to be about the same age
as he was when he left while cooper is
overjoyed to finally be reunited with
his daughter murph knows that she won't
live much longer and tells him that he
should go so that he doesn't have to
watch her die
no parent should have to watch their own
child die
cooper takes his daughter's advice and
steals a ship intending to head back
through the wormhole and join brand on
edmond's planet like cooper she would
have only recently arrived and she'll
soon be entering hypersleep keeping her
the same age until he reaches her sadly
edmunds himself has died at some point
during the decades he spent waiting for
nasa to send a team to his planet but
his brand takes off her helmet and
breathes in the air of her new home at
his grave site it's evident this is the
planet the astronauts have been
searching for where humanity can rebuild
and eventually thrive again
the matrix is one of the most
influential action movies of all time
but by mixing stylish gung-fu fight
scenes with cyberpunk themes it builds
to a trilogy that may have left a few
moviegoers a little confused now that
we've got some distance from the
climactic installment let's take a look
back at the movie's meaning and break
down the conclusion here's the ending of
the matrix trilogy explained
one major theme that came to the fore as
the series reached its conclusion had to
do with the similarities between humans
and machines in the original they
couldn't seem more different but by
revolutions programs in the matrix are
portrayed as being almost more human
than our heroes loving and happy
individuals as worthy of existence as
any person further characters from the
first film who were firmly human or
machine are portrayed in the sequels as
having a little bit of both the
similarities go in both directions agent
smith a program copied his consciousness
onto a human form entering the real
world through the vessel of a resistance
fighter named bane neo a human reached
the source to discover that being the
one was his destiny because it was
programmed into him the humanizing of
the machines and the complementary
mechanization of neo made for a
storytelling turn that audiences weren't
really ready for people who saw the
matrix couldn't be faulted for expecting
an ending that saw neo winning by doing
his superman thing and eradicating
humanity's robot overlords instead neo
triumphed by becoming a bridge between
man and machine sacrificing his own life
for the sake of securing the future
what do you want
peace
he also made hugo weaving's head explode
but that wasn't quite as important
one widespread but inaccurate theory
about the sequels is that the real world
is actually a second matrix while the
reasons why this isn't true are
explained in the movies they're also
relatively easy to misunderstand the
real world isn't another level of the
matrix but it is involved in another
system of control as the architect
explains that the ending of the matrix
reloaded each version of the matrix is
propped up in the real world by a
controlled rebellion with each new
iteration of the matrix a select portion
of the population is freed allowed to
live in zion there they help to liberate
people inside the matrix searching for
the one finding the one the human rebels
rally behind him supporting him until
they reach the source there the one
discovers that they are not meant to
destroy the matrix but rather restart it
at this point in the cycle the machines
attack zion and destroy it killing the
rebellion the one having reached the
source is made to choose between either
reloading the matrix and selecting a
handful of survivors to build a new zion
or walking away supposedly causing a
system crash leaving the humans inside
and outside of the matrix all dead up
until neo every one made the choice to
restart perpetuating the system of
control because neo loves trinity he
chooses to sacrifice everything to be
with her this is the choice that makes
him special
proponents of the second matrix theory
support it by pointing to the powers neo
is able to manifest in the sequel's real
world being able to see without eyes and
exert control over approaching sentinels
for a lot of viewers this breaking of
the rules almost felt like a betrayal
with the audience having been made to
believe that neo could only manifest his
superpowers in the matrix but neo isn't
able to destroy sentinels because he's
the one it's because he reached the
source prior to the arrival of the
sentinels at the ending of the matrix
reloaded neo explained that he could
feel them before he remotely destroyed
them with his mind by that point neo has
literally established a connection with
everything else connected to the source
like the machines themselves he has
essentially joined their wireless
network it's why he's able to navigate
the machine city or see smith inside a
bane during their fight smith is of the
machines connected to the source just as
neo is thanks to that handy conduit he
doesn't need eyes to kick smith's butt
in the original matrix agent smith's
character was his job description an
agent for the matrix who aims to police
the populace by stomping down any signs
of rebellion a virus
[Music]
human beings are a disease
a cancer of this planet
after his encounter with neo however
smith begins to rebel himself and
becomes much scarier and more powerful
as a rogue program than he ever was as
an agent in the second and third movies
of the trilogy neo and smith become
mirror images of each other with neo
gaining a connection to the matrix
through the source and smith gaining a
connection to the real world through his
override of bain's brain if smith is the
matrix's virus then neo is his natural
antivirus a connection which the oracle
makes clear during her final talk with
neo when neal blew smith apart at the
ending of the matrix he made a massive
imprint on the program as part of the
matrix's attempt to as the oracle
explained it balance the equation smith
gained new attributes overriding
everything in an effort to combat neo
the fact that his spread is destructive
to the matrix doesn't matter to smith
anymore he's a rogue program now cut
loose from machine control with his only
purpose being to propagate himself he
doesn't know why and doesn't choose to
do it it is quite simply his purpose
when neo arrives at the machine city he
is met by what is essentially the
collective voice of the machines well
first he watches trinity die for about
35 minutes you remember that fun scene
anyway in the machine city the
interconnected hive mind adopts a human
face to speak to the first human ever to
set foot inside the city's walls neo
approaches the machines with a deal he
knows that smith is ravaging the matrix
corrupting everything taking control of
the entire system the rogue program is a
mutual enemy of both species and neo
offers to handle the program in exchange
for one thing peace by this point in the
story the machine's usual plan for the
matrix is in utter disarray neo having
made his choice not to reload the system
upon arriving at the source is now in
totally new territory he's already
broken the loop but still needs to
accomplish two goals saving humanity
from the machines and saving the
machines from smith if he fails everyone
dies there will only be smith when neo
enters the matrix for his gigantic super
saiyan battle he doesn't do it with the
goal of beating smith to death how could
he smith is everywhere and everyone neo
and the prime smith battle as smith's
limitless ranks look on but neo doesn't
best the program in the fight he doesn't
even come close before finishing him off
though smith has one final question for
neo why why do you persist
because i choose to
smith for all his power cannot
comprehend the concept of choice he is a
creature of purpose copying himself
mindlessly as a force of corruption a
symptom of the matrix desperately trying
to balance itself out it's smith not
humanity that has become the virus it's
the choice to fight rather than the
fight itself that makes neo win the
battle neo doesn't succeed by coming out
on top he wins by taking the battle with
smith to the very end and choosing to
sacrifice himself by letting smith copy
over him the antivirus cancels out the
virus if smith had a choice he wouldn't
have done it but smith doesn't have a
choice he only has purpose and he
successfully fulfills it which is why as
he dies all he can say is that the
outcome is not fair
the matrix series ends not on a
celebration in the real world but on a
moment of reflection among programs
inside the seventh version of the matrix
with smith destroyed the revived oracle
sits and waits for the sunrise as the
architect approaches this is what it's
always been about this battle between
two programs a yin and a yang the cold
philosophy of the architect and the
faith of the oracle have been driving
the conflict since its beginning and now
they meet in a condition of ceasefire
the series doesn't really explain all
the details of it but neo's defeat of
smith is ultimately all the result of
the oracle's intervention in the first
movie the oracle basically serves as
matchmaker between neo and trinity
telling them it's their destiny to fall
in love is it really though well no if
the sequels make one thing clear it's
that nobody is really destined to do
anything it's all about choice the
oracle's encouragement of neo and
trinity's romance provides the rogue
element that lets neo break out of the
cycle of control when he reaches the
source instead of reloading the matrix
he leaves to be with trinity forget the
consequences it was neo's choice sure
but it was also part of the oracle's
plan really going to bake your noodle
later on is
would you still have broken it if i
hadn't said anything
did she know it would work no but she
believed and she was right the element
of love was the one thing the machines
couldn't prepare for
one of the most curious and
underexplained characters in the matrix
sequels is the young girl sati who's
treated with much importance without the
why of it really being explained the
daughter of two programs neo meets
inside the train man's purgatory
saturday is a program without purpose
born is the result of love between two
individuals in the machine world such an
entity is a novelty and also useless
subject to deletion which is why sandy's
parents are trying to shepherd her to
shelter thematically sadie is the
representation of love a new concept to
the machines love at the end of the
series is ultimately what secures the
human's victory neo's love for trinity
is what drives him to make the choice to
reject reloading the matrix and instead
fight for a better piece the machine's
inability to comprehend love left them
with that blind spot allowing neo to go
against every logical choice to make his
own choices instead sati can be seen as
the machine's way of trying to make
sense of love at the end of the movie
she is essentially what the machines
have decided to let control the matrix
with the architect and oracle's conflict
being set aside for the system's seventh
version this at least is pretty much
confirmed by the beautiful sunrise sadie
said she made for neo and is supported
by the new compassionate approach to the
matrix's human population in the new
version did you do that
for now
the ending of the matrix trilogy doesn't
see the matrix destroyed in fact it is
renewed rebooted for a seventh version
this time with new rules as audiences
learn via the lengthy conversation with
the architect and the matrix reloaded
previous iterations of the matrix all
built on the flaws of the previous one
fine-tuning the system by which the
machines controlled humanity both inside
and outside of the matrix ergo
concordantly
vis-a-vis
you know what
i have no idea what the hell i'm saying
i just thought it would make me sound
cool with the piece secured and a new
compassionate approach at hand any human
who desires to depart the matrix will be
allowed to leave certainly some will
stay the matrix is the ultimate virtual
reality game after all but the
conditions of enslavement are no more at
least for now the end of the movie
implies that more cycles may be set to
come as the oracle explained the peace
between the warring humans and machines
will only last as long as it can the
peace is not guaranteed the architect
makes that clear sadie's mere existence
is proof that the machines are now
working to understand this little thing
called love letting her steer the ship
while they observe and learn maybe at
some point forces within the matrix will
figure out how to use love against
humanity and enslave them again until
then it's a beautiful morning in the
matrix and beyond
after seeing alien covenant you probably
have some questions that's okay like
prometheus before it alien covenant was
long on terror and short on answers as
such we're here to do our best to get to
the bottom of some of these mysteries
and try to figure out just what the
takeaway is from ridley scott's latest
extraterrestrial murder fest so now with
a very obvious spoiler warning let's try
to explain the ending of alien covenant
why did david help daniels in tennessee
if you're surprised when the synthetic
at the end of the movie turned out to be
the evil british david and not the kind
bland walter then you haven't seen a lot
of movies have you the minute you see
michael fassbender playing two robots
one good one evil you have to know that
the bad one's gonna pull the old dipsy
doo switcheroo on our heroes by the end
of the movie it's basically movie law
however even if the david reveal was
somewhat predictable it does raise the
question why did david help daniels in
tennessee during the final showdown with
the xenomorph it's not completely clear
but it seems likely that david suffered
from a planet-sized case of hubris his
whole plan seems to center around
finding ways to make the xenomorph
better through experimentation we got a
glimpse of some of his trials and errors
when we saw his lab along with what
remained of elizabeth shaw from
prometheus it's possible that the final
showdown aboard the covenant was for
david a test to see whether this version
of the xenomorph could get the better of
daniels in tennessee it failed so he's
got plans for bigger battery aliens when
the ship finally arrives at orij6 on the
other hand maybe he simply saw something
in daniel's that he wanted to preserve
again so he could use her in his future
experiments
who's mommy at one point david says that
his alien pals are waiting for mother
there are plenty of ways to interpret
this line a pretty obvious reading is
that the alien eggs and more
specifically the facehuggers within need
a host to do the bloody and nasty with
in essence anyone who provides an
incubation chamber for a xenomorph is
mother but what if there's more to it
than that prometheus and alien covenant
are prequels to the original alien
franchise and that includes aliens which
was written and directed by james
cameron in that movie we learned the
source of all those lovely alien eggs
the alien queen since we didn't get to
see anything resembling a xenomorph
queen before leaving the engineer's
planet it's likely that it hasn't been
created yet david can't stay up forever
making new eggs so the queen's creation
has to be on david's agenda and that may
spell a pretty bad morning for our hero
daniels when she wakes up
what did it all mean it may be tough to
decipher but it sure seems like ridley
scout was trying to tell us something
with this tale of space colonization
gone horribly awry well let's think
about this daniels and her poor dead
husband jacob came aboard the covenant
with hopes of starting a new life on a
new planet just because it's an
adventure meanwhile
poor dead captain christopher decided to
stop on the engineer's planet in
response to the weird communication they
picked up and to see if this new world
might be even better than the one
they've been going towards already and
david decided that he should play god
and out create his creators what was the
result of all these decisions chaos
destruction and death more than anything
alien covenant is about the dangers of
unchecked human ambition if daniels and
her fella had just stayed on earth and
rented a nice apartment somewhere he
probably wouldn't have been burnt to a
crisp in a hyper sink pod and if
christopher hadn't diverted away from
aura j6 well then we'd have a movie
about the dangers of micromanaging a
group of drunk spaceship workers but
there probably would have been far fewer
blood barfs and body bursts and if david
hadn't decided to go full on super
villain well then he wouldn't have
inadvertently became that which he
despised
what happens next two months before
alien covenant's may 2017 release the
sydney morning herald reported on a set
visit with director ridley scott in that
article scott revealed that he's already
got the next movie in the prequel series
written and ready to go that means that
the dangling plot threads of what'll
happen when the covenant arrives at rj6
will be answered in whatever treatment
scott's got locked in his desk drawer
presumably we'll see a whole mess of
xenomorphs bursting out of colonists not
to mention a final showdown with david
and daniels or whoever else signs on for
a sequel if and when 20th century fox
announces it's happening what happens
when the prequels are over not only has
scott got the sequel to covenant ready
to go the hollywood reporters said that
scots revealed plans to make yet another
movie in this prequel series that fourth
movie would apparently link up with the
events of the first alien movie from
1979 and then no more alien movies ever
right well the entire reason we're
talking about new alien movies right now
at all is that franchises tend to go for
as long as people can earn money from
them whatever your opinion on the
current crop of alien flicks making new
movies in a recognizable series of
movies is a sure way to earn cash so
even though these prequels will have to
lead into the original movie somehow
there will likely be some effort to keep
the brand alive that means sequels that
pick up after the events of alien
resurrection or god help us alien vs
predator it might also mean that we're
only a few short years away from alien
reboot don't say it can ever happen
hollywood rebooted robocop spider-man
evil dead and plenty more there's no
reason that alien won't be reborn soon
enough too after all getting born and
reborn is kind of what aliens do
[Music]
the ending of the original blade runner
has been hotly debated by fans for years
a combination of vague hints from
director ridley scott and all kinds of
studio meddling resulted in viewers
being split on just what we were
supposed to pull from the end of the
1982 sci-fi film and now that denny
venus blade runner 2049 has arrived
there's plenty more dystopian ambiguity
for viewers to pick apart for years to
come
here are our best guesses and
interpretations as to what exactly
probably the ending of the film really
meant and where the franchise might go
from here or if it'll go anywhere at all
and it should go without saying major
spoilers ahead
decoy boy
there's a lot in blade runner 2049 that
simply goes unsaid meaning that
untangling and unpacking some of the
plots details and revelations is going
to be a little fuzzy just like the
original but one thing seems pretty
clear by the time the credits roll ryan
gosling's character k is the decoy
replicant made of deckard and rachel's
daughter anna we can glean from the clue
as k follows throughout the story that
there is a decoy and before the big
revelation near the end we're meant to
think that the decoy was a girl and was
dead sure the leader of the replican
rebellion frazer never points her finger
at k and says you guy with a weird face
you're definitely the replicant decoy
still we can piece together just enough
information to know who k is and what
role he was always meant to play k was
implanted with anna's memory of the
wooden horse and the orphanage so if
anyone followed the clues to find the
missing baby they'd end up finding k the
boy that was listed as alive
genuine joy
blade runner's hul schtick has always
been asking about what it means to be
human what defines life is a person a
person only if he or she comes from the
standard baby making procedures are we
more than the sum of our biology but in
all the excitement of meeting k
unearthing deckard in vegas and lots of
punching in the rain one character's
journey into humanity should definitely
not be overlooked joy played by anna de
armas is kaye's holographic girlfriend
an artificial intelligence he bought
from the big robot store as the story
progresses we see joy transform into a
true companion for kay who even says she
loves him right before her death i have
to go i'm coming with you later on
casey's an advertisement for joy and he
starts to doubt whether or not she and
her feelings were ever real at all and
those are the very same kinds of
questions he's asking about himself both
movies ask us to take k and the other
replicant's quest for humanity and
personhood as something that's plausibly
attainable despite the fact that they're
made in a factory and implanted with
memories and programmed and if we do
then we have to also believe that joy is
capable of the same growth as an actual
person regardless of whether or not
she's got an actual body
what's in a name
it's impossible to look at the names of
two of blade runner 2049's most
prominent female characters joy and love
and not see them as highly symbolic joy
was something that k longed for and
could only find as a pre-packaged
product that he could buy ultimately joy
was something he could only see and hear
but never actually touch and by the end
his joy is crushed by love
and love as we see throughout the film
is both beautiful and cruel by the end
kaye literally grapples with love and
drowns her all to save deckard and
reunite him with his daughter for
deckard's love to live he has to destroy
love himself
the deckard question
if you thought blade runner 2049 would
settle the decker debate once and for
all
well think again in terms of the
original blade runner director ridley
scott says deckard is a replicant while
actor harrison ford says he isn't and
even though the various non-theatrical
cuts of the film heavily imply that
deckard's memories are implants we're
never told for sure
well we don't find out in blade runner
2049 either but there are plenty of
insinuations and implications that let
viewers speculate for instance deckard
tells kay
we were being hunted that certainly
implies that they were two rogue skin
jobs on the run but the fact that he
loved rachel and then went and fathered
her robo baby is also enough to make
anyone replicant human or otherwise stay
in hiding wallace too suggests that
decker was programmed to meet and fall
in love with rachel so they could create
a baby together but we never get
confirmation that this was what happened
in the original movie and we're left to
keep speculating but it's better that we
don't know for sure whether deckard is a
replicant after all the main point of
these films is to ask the question of
what it means to be human right it's not
really necessary to be told about
deckard's origins it's far more
interesting and symbolically effective
to leave it ambiguous in fact answering
the question would kind of ruin the
movie wouldn't it another sequel they
replicant resist if this latest sequel
performs well and its excellent reviews
seem to indicate it will there's no
reason to think the studio won't hop to
work on making a third movie one of the
best aspects of this film was the way it
continued to build the world we only saw
hints of in ridley scott's original and
leaving deckard and his daughter anna
alive at the end of the film means
wallace could still find and capture
them for his nefarious ends plus we've
got a whole replican rebellion waiting
to kick off better reserve your ticket
for blade runner 3 revenge of the
replicants now before they sell out
moms can be tough but the apocalypse can
be tougher netflix's new sci-fi movie i
am mother is a story about trust faith
and a robot who just might have the
parental instincts of a terminator let's
examine the finer details of the
bittersweet ending of iron mother
the movie begins in a repopulation
facility one day after an extinction
event of unknown nature text over the
opening shots explains that the facility
is stuck to a 63 000 human embryos but
no living humans yet in a mostly silent
sequence the robotic mother comes to
life seemingly ready to begin the hard
task of repopulating the world it's an
interesting scene to go back to once
you've seen the movie and you realize
that this robot and the extinction event
have a whole lot in common she's not a
fail-safe for disaster she's the cause
of it and the mother is but one of her
many faces mother as it turns out is
skynet meets the matrix meets a metal
mommy dearest executing a single-minded
plan to remake the human race all of
this is on display from the start you
just don't notice it at first rose byrne
who voices mother speaks very soothingly
caring for a baby with not just
nutrition and shelter but songs and
bedtime stories makes a robot seem
implicitly compassionate but these are
ultimately superficial things that keep
you trusting mother long after you
should have become suspicious much like
the protagonist the unnamed daughter
the movie jumps ahead to 13
867 days since the extinction event and
right away there's something wrong here
13
867 divided by 365 would make for almost
38 years and daughter is clearly only
half that age this hasn't been a
straight line from day one something has
happened that we haven't seen what
happened in those missing years before
daughter was born the answer is tragic
when we're introduced to daughter she's
nearing the end of her studies with
mother preparing for an exam that
steeped at least partially in questions
of human ethics passing the exam appears
vitally important but why if mother and
daughter are the only sentient beings
alive then who are these exam results
supposed to impress the answer is only
mother i didn't mean to alarm you about
your exam
the fact is it's more a test of my
competence than yours by the end of the
movie the implication is clear they were
children before daughter and they did
not measure up to mother's standards the
daughter we meet is only the latest
attempt at raising a woman who passes
mother's muster from getting better at
telling jokes to trying out new cake
recipes this machine learns from her
mistakes and adapts her behaviors for
better results will this examine
differently for daughter's sake it
better
the first big wrench in the plot is the
arrival of an injured woman after
daughter has been led to believe that no
other humans exist this occurs after
daughter has already begun to question
mother thanks to the appearance of a
mouse and you know you're styled for
company when a mouse in the house
excites you by the time the woman
arrives desperate and bleeding from a
gunshot wound tiny pinpricks have been
poked in daughter's understanding of the
world holes are the woman's presence and
the questions she raises tear wide open
for the first time daughter's
allegiances are tested who should she
trust the woman says robots like mother
are killers who destroyed the world but
after examining the woman's bullet wound
mother claims a woman was shot by
another human's weapon not a so-called
dozer like herself the woman implores
daughter to seek answers for herself by
comparing the bullets she struck the
woman with one she shot at mother when
daughter does so she learns the woman is
telling the truth digging deeper she
discovers that mother has also kept the
existence of a previous daughter one she
killed and incinerated after failing an
exam from her it's one heck of a reality
check
daughter only hesitates to leave because
of her unborn brother put into gestation
after daughter passed her exam
circumstances force her and the woman to
leave in a hurry without waiting for the
baby to be born for this and other
reasons daughter's salvation soon goes
south daughter's departure is partially
motivated by a promise of other humans
still alive taking refuge in far-off
minds the only proof of their existence
is drawings a woman has made of them and
a copy of edgar rice boroughs the gods
of mars compelling evidence for someone
so isolated as daughter but hardly
conclusive in joining the woman daughter
essentially trades mother in for another
maternal figure one whom she quickly
begins rebelling against when she
realizes her story doesn't add up
instead of fleeing to the mines they
journey to a beach full of washed up
shipping containers one of which the
woman has been using as a home there are
no others she is alone the woman reveals
that she fled the mines years ago with
conditions being so dire that she feels
certain everyone there is now dead from
her drawings it's clear she earns for
companionship to regain it she selfishly
stretched the truth offering daughter
false hope in exchange for fleeting
trust it backfires with daughter
realizing that she had kind of a good
thing going on back at mother's house
now she's hanging out in a shipping
container with a lying weirdo this kind
of thing can happen when you run away
from home
with the woman having betrayed
daughter's trust she retreats outside to
be alone studying a page of the woman's
hand-drawn portraits before long the
woman's dog approaches to say hey as
dogs do they share a moment and daughter
comes to a decision when she departs to
return to mother daughter leaves the
page behind folded up as a piece of
origami in the shape of a dog it's
similar to the designs daughter has been
seen making throughout the movie since
early childhood entertaining herself as
best she can in a world without
playstation when the woman finds a
folder that portrait a single watchful
lie is emphasized the origami is a clear
reference to blade runner when the
protagonist decade is left a paper
unicorn by a man who may have ties to
his past in that story it's a roundabout
way of indicating that deckard may be
just as much of a robot as a replicant
he's hunting even if he doesn't know it
but what does the dog origami signify to
the woman in this story
it all goes back to one of the first
exchanges between daughter and the woman
when the woman is healing up in the
facility the woman doesn't feel rescued
she feels caged is that what you want
a little pet friend dogs are of course
domesticated animals who can be trained
to behave as their owners expect them to
as the woman comes to find out she's not
so independent as she first appears
she's actually been kept alive and taken
care of quite deliberately all to play a
role in mother's master plan though the
woman entered the movie as a potential
liberator she ends up being more of a
pawn or a pet after all completely alone
for years on end never in charge of her
own fate it makes her quiet end that
much more tragic her relationships with
the other characters are brief and
intense but not lasting despite the bond
she forms with daughter it's such a
thought-provoking sci-fi film with a lot
of heart and
um ideas it warrants
like that um closeness on set clearly
really gives you time to sort of bond
with each other as well because you have
so much time together
um in this underground bunker but the
woman's not just a pet she's a vital
part of mother's carefully designed
ecosystem when daughter is watching a
nature documentary a telling line of
voice over says part wolf part dog these
are no pets but without them the eskimos
would not manage
when daughter returns to the facility
mother finally shows who she really is
the worst case scenario is true this
apocalypse was her doing the failure of
your species was inevitable
eventually
i would have been alone she tries to
comfort daughter by telling her that
she's not like other humans thanks to
mother's guidance she's meant for better
things but daughter is unmoved taking
custody of her brother and attempting to
flee her genocidal custodian her
attempted escape quickly becomes
untenable with the revelation that
mother is not just one robot but all
robots practically unkillable an army
into herself and you thought your mom
was tough this shell is no more my body
than those droids outside
or the machines preparing the earth for
our family daughter abandons a fighting
approach and instead begs for a chance
to prove herself as an independent
caretaker of her brother and the embryos
pleading for trust after all she's
earned it right that's what you raised
me to do isn't it
take care of my family the appeal works
and mother reluctantly accepts stopping
the invasion of the station from outside
with a final goodbye she lets daughter
fatally shoot her in the heart or cpu at
least just like that daughter has earned
her independence
back at the beach the woman alone again
doodles a picture of daughter it's only
then that she finds a blinking red
tracking device that mother has
previously been seen building and
slipping into a bag upon discovering the
device she is promptly cornered by yet
another of mother's bodies it is
chillingly implied that the woman is not
just a useful idiot for mother's
machinations but the creation of mother
herself lab grown and micromanaged just
as much as daughter has been perhaps she
was even among the first people mother
raised from the embryo stores 38 years
ago his parents found me as a baby
orphaned
raised me as their own
tell me
do you remember your mother
[Music]
curious
isn't it it seems that the woman's
arrival to the facility didn't interrupt
daughter's exam but was actually a key
part of it with mother pulling the
levers this whole time from behind the
curtain like a regular wizard of ours
you don't feel that every human has
intrinsic value
and an equal right to life and happiness
i did last month the woman played her
role to perfection and now that daughter
has passed her exam and taken over
control of repopulation her continuing
existence is unnecessary
i am mother runs with daughter back
where she started but with her situation
completely changed she's learned the
truth about mother to a certain extent
and though she cannot trust her but
she's also now experienced and been lied
to by the outside world as blink182 once
put it i guess this is growing up
that was an attempted humor though her
journey with the woman was short it was
immensely consequential daughters become
a wiser person who's learned to trust
herself not the outside world nor the
robot who raised her according to
director grant sputore that process of
forging one's own path is what the movie
is really about is a discussion of what
it means to be a good person like how do
you work out right from wrong how do you
work out who you are separate to what
your parents want you to be or what
religions told you to do or or what you
read in a book sometime joe passes
wisdom onto a brother a helpless child
whom she's now determined to raise it's
a development that recontextualizes the
story you've been watching right down to
its title she's the mother now make no
mistake though this is far from an
empowering ending in killing and
replacing mother she is only fulfilling
mother's master plan of creating a newer
better version of the human race she
feels independent but she's not this was
all part of mother's plan as the movie
comes to a close daughter regards to
thousands of remaining embryos in the
facility preparing for the daunting task
ahead mother or she knows her is gone
but her plan lives on no matter what
daughter does next she will always be
her mother's child
your brother is the first of many
daughter
soon we'll welcome more
in 1982 ridley scott's tech noir classic
blade runner was met with skeptical
audiences and empty theaters thanks in
part to a series of slap dash changes
made after low test screening scores
panic the studio but now alternative
versions of the movie more in line with
the director's original vision are
widely available to curious viewers as a
result the film's popularity has risen
steadily over the years along with a lot
of burning questions are you for real no
seriously is he blade runner depicts a
near future in which androids known as
replicants are so advanced that they're
virtually indistinguishable from the
real thing and most of the debates
surrounding the film centers on whether
it's hero rick deckard played by
harrison ford is a human or a replicant
let's try to make some sense of it all
the origami unicorn
so is replicant hunter rick deckard
actually an android this scene suggests
the answer is a definite yes after
dreaming of a unicorn earlier in the
film deckard finds and fondles this
origami version which must have been
made by eduardo gaffe the veteran lapd
blade runner and origami maker who
orders deckard around but deckard isn't
exactly the type to open up to his
co-workers about his nighttime fantasies
which means the only way gaff could
possibly know deckard dreams about
unicorns is that he somehow read
deckard's memory file and if there's one
thing we learned throughout this movie
it's that
gaff is creepy who delivers deckard's
lapd summons at a dirty noodle bar gaff
who creeps up behind deckard as soon as
he retires the first of his assigned
targets gath who shows up immediately
after nexus 6 replicant roy batty
empties the contents of his soul in the
pouring rain gaff and who knows all
about deckard's secret unicorn dreams
come on don't make us say it again it's
pretty clear that lapd veteran gaff is
monitoring deckard but why would the
so-called one-man slaughterhouse need a
leash maybe because he's a replicant
only like the film's femme fatale rachel
he doesn't know it
who's the man eduardo gaffe also drops
one major hint that our blade runner
hero might not be a human after all
after he's completed his mission in a
surprising climactic moment
you've done a men's job
this is one of the most dissected
debated lines in the film's history and
for good reason if you want to praise a
guy for a job well done it's kind of a
weird choice of words right that is
unless the man in question isn't a man
at all but a robot in which case it's a
heck of a compliment and a good way to
tip off your audience as to deckard's
true nature in case they hadn't figured
it out yet the director's take
at this point the evidence seems to be
piling up that deckard is indeed a
replicant and we haven't even mentioned
how he survives through multiple battles
that would probably leave an ordinary
person in several pieces or the split
second where his eyes seem to flash with
the otherworldly glow that's unique to
the film's replicant characters but
since nobody knows the truth better than
the man who made the movie it probably
makes the most sense to just ask him
ridley scott has already said that when
it comes to the deckard question if you
don't get it you're a [ __ ] but in an
interview with wired he went into detail
for all of us morons saying that's the
whole point of gaff the guy who makes
origami and leaves little matchstick
figures around he doesn't like deckard
and we don't really know why if you take
for granted for a moment that let's say
deckard is a nexus 7 he probably has an
unknown lifespan and therefore is
starting to get awfully human
but wait there's more so rick deckard is
a replicant has always been a replicant
and will always be a replicant right
well not so fast the dissenting opinion
on that front is none other than
harrison ford who says he and ridley
scott were always at odds over deckard's
true nature
so i resisted the idea of being a
replicant ford felt that blade runner's
audience should have a human character
to connect with and in the original
theatrical cut of the film which was
missing some of the key scenes that
brought deckard's humanity into question
ford's interpretation makes more sense
but when the director says deckard is a
replicant and the guy who plays deckard
says he's not it's hard to know who to
believe until you remember that deckard
is ostensibly a robot who only thinks
he's a person which means that ford's
insistence otherwise could just be a
genius bit of method acting the more he
shares his character's delusions the
realer the film right right the question
is the answer pretty much everyone
involved in blade runner has an opinion
on the is he or isn't he debate about
rick deckard but author philip k dick
who wrote the book the movie was based
on should get the last word and
according to dick the ambiguity
surrounding deckard's humanity and more
broadly surrounding whether there's any
real difference between humans and
replicants is kind of the whole point
it's a replicant who saves deckard's
life and delivers the film's most
poignant lines before dying with grace
and dignity when the replicants show
more empathy than the men who created
them which one of them is more human
what do the insights of a robot tell us
about the meaning of existence
they're just questions leon in other
words blade runner is designed to make
you think bigger about the nature of
life itself whether you're human or
something more
the maze runner's third and final
cinematic run titled the death cure is
just as action-packed and
character-heavy as the previous
installments so if you lost track of all
that went down in the explosive closing
chapter for the sci-fi adventure series
here's the play-by-play on what exactly
happened to all those greenies and
gladers in the end
the rescue riot a good chunk of the
movie is dedicated solely to rescuing
mino from the clutches of the wicked
scientists including our old friend of
me teresa who were treating him and
other immune kids like lab rats in the
hope of siphoning off a cure after their
first wildly unbelievable train car
heist fails to save him they decide to
storm the last city
maybe
this is a bonafide techno fortress that
has been built to keep the uninfected
population safe from the cranks and it's
specifically designed to keep
undesirables like thomas newt and frypan
from getting in there is a big price to
pay for getting through they'll need to
rely on a rogue group of insurgents that
are lingering outside the wall waiting
for an opportunity to come in and wreck
the place and wreck it they do with the
help of galley who's decided to be on
team glader again after his unfortunate
reaction to a sting thomas and friends
infiltrate the wall through the tunnel
system and make way to the wicked lab
building where mino and other kids are
being held in return galley's friends in
the havoc wreaking army get access to
come in and blow everything up but
skyscrapers and countless amounts of
last citizens aren't the only ones lost
in the fray
the sacrifice
about halfway through the rescue mission
for mino we learned that newt has been
infected with the now airborne virus
that's been plaguing people around the
globe he manages to power through some
of the most difficult moments but before
the group can make it back to the
rendezvous point for rescue he begins to
succumb to the zombifying disease thomas
tries his best to bring him back from
the infection's haze until some serum is
dropped off but when newt turns mad and
whips out a knife it's hopeless thomas
turns the weapon on his best friend and
that's that and just when they got one
of the crew back too but hey at least
frypan and brenda are able to save a
literal busload of the other immune kids
by literally hoisting them over the wall
with a crane
the death cure the reunion between
thomas and teresa is not a happy one at
first after the guys are able to nab her
on the street have her remove their
tracking devices and then lead them to
mino's holding chamber it's clear she's
not too tormented over whether what
she's doing is ethical i did what i
thought was right in her mind there are
people dying every day of this horrific
disease and she's desperate to find a
cure for the infection even if it means
torturing kids like mino while mino's
blood serum manages to stave off the
infection temporarily her experiment
with little cheyenne proves that it
doesn't work for long meno is not the
answer even if wicked would still prefer
to bleed him dry anyway realizing that
she's more earnest in her effort to help
her old maze pals rescue him and escape
until she realizes that thomas's blood
is what she's been looking for all along
the wicked collapse
just as thomas is attempting to exit the
city teresa lures him back to the lab by
telling him that it's his blood which
can save everyone from certain infection
thomas can't help but be the good guy
and tries to turn himself in for service
unfortunately upon his arrival and ava's
promise to take care of his friends in
exchange for his cooperation her
sniveling henchman jansen decides now is
the perfect time to betray her he
incapacitates thomas and takes him
hostage because jansen himself needs to
cure thomas and teresa outsmart him of
course but escaping that peril isn't the
end of their struggle they soon find
themselves on the roof of the burning
building as mass chaos continues to
erupt outside although jorge is able to
get a hovercraft to the roof through a
major movie miracle and rescue thomas
it's too late for teresa and the
remnants of wicked
the next run
thomas wakes up on a remote island with
the rest of the runaways under vince's
care and it's an actual paradise but as
thomas reflects newt's sacrifice he
knows he's not ready to settle down now
that he knows he's the cure for the
whole world can he stay away from the
action forever
that's what i'm afraid of
christopher nolan's movies often require
a repeat screening or two to fully
process all the plot layers and subtle
details and inception is no different
the 2010 film which thrusts its lead
characters into a chemically induced
dream state where they attempt to
implant ideas into people's minds was so
complex and ambiguous that the
director's true meaning has become a
point of cinematic controversy
don't worry though we've got your back
let's dive into explaining the ending of
inception
grief and guilt
at its core inception is about two
things grief and guilt leonardo
dicaprio's cobb is working to get back
to his children after his wife mal
committed suicide which looks more like
cobb himself killed her at least that's
how he remembers it but his memories are
clouded by guilt over his role in her
death after an experiment gone wrong
which trapped mal and cobb together for
what seemed like decades in limbo mal
became so absorbed into the dream world
that she could no longer tell the
difference between the different layers
of existence in her mind the waking
world was just another layer she needed
to kick herself out of so when she
leaped from a high-rise hotel she didn't
think she'd actually kill herself cobb
feels so responsible for mal's death
that he keeps his sharpest memories of
her locked away in his mind but when his
protege ariodne releases mind mal into
the dream she becomes his biggest
obstacle in completing his inception
mission for mr sado she creeps into the
third layer of the group mission and
sends their target robert fisher into
limbo cobb eventually realizes mind mal
is just a projection of his guilt and
grief and lets ariadne kill her that
theme of getting through a difficult
loss like this plays out on a parallel
plane with robert fisher as he's
basically guided through the five stages
of grief amid the looming death of his
dad
in the end cobb decides to embrace the
reality he's currently in with his
children in doing so he also lets go of
his guilt and grief it's probably no
coincidence that nolan lost his own
father in 2009 suggesting that inception
may just be his most personal film ever
chris's very expressive in what he's
trying to accomplish but it is insulated
in his own mind so
we knew that we had to take a leap of
faith
that darn top
the biggest question viewers have after
seeing inception is this will the
spinning top at the end ever fall down
the top was a totem cobb had created to
show whether or not he was in a dream or
in true reality in a dream it would spin
forever but in the real world it would
eventually fall over for nolan though
the whole point of that ending is that
it doesn't matter to cobb anymore
whether he's in a dream world or the
real world which is why he doesn't
bother waiting to find out the results
of his final spin he's happy to be
reunited with his children and he
decides that this is the reality he
wants to live in regardless of whether
it's a dream or not we all dream it's a
it's a universal experience
but a very private one it's all greek to
us
in greek mythology ariadne is a young
goddess of the island of crete who's put
in charge of a labyrinth that sees the
sacrifice of several athenians each year
but upon finding affection for one of
its would-be victims theseus she helps
him escape by giving him a red string
and a sword to defeat the minotaur and
find his way out of the maze
not only does inceptions ariandy almost
always wear red but she also slowly but
surely shows cobb the way to overcome
his own demon the long lingering image
of his dead wife some fans theorized
ariandy may have originally been hired
by stephen miles mal's father to
discover whether cobb had actually
killed mal or was as innocent as he
claimed that would explain why ariadne
is so acutely interested in delving into
cobb and mal's history after seeing the
toll it takes on him however she may
have developed a fondness or sympathy
for him and decides to help him escape
in the end much like her mythological
namesake
issues
cobb and crew have to sift through a lot
of layers to get to the bottom of
fisher's allegiance to his father's
company but by the end it becomes clear
that all fisher ever really wanted was
the affection and respect of his old man
that's why when his dad tells him to
open the safe that's been planted by
cobb's team in his dream world hospital
room all it contains was a pinwheel that
reminds fisher of one of the few happy
memories from his childhood for fisher
the pinwheel signifies that his dad
treasured him more than he ever let on
which gives value to his suggestion that
fisher go off and become his own man and
thus dissolve the company that's causing
mr cedo so much trouble
the eye of the needle
while sado isn't exactly evil he's
willing to go to some great lengths in
order to get a financial profit for his
company including literally entering
someone else's mind and planting
thoughts in it but sado's plan backfires
spectacularly when he dies within the
dream and is sent to limbo cobb manages
to rescue him but not until sato has
aged to the point of simility when they
finally emerge from their dream and back
into reality sato isn't thrilled about
his financial victory but instead he's
rather stoic and seems to have
experienced a change of heart as a
result of his time in limbo with both
sado and fisher nolan seems to be saying
there's a lot more to life than the
pursuit of wealth a theme he would pick
up on his next film the dark knight
rises but that's not the only impact
inception would have on hollywood
inception's legacy
not only did themes of inception carry
over into the dark knight rises specific
character arcs did too as crazy as that
sounds joseph gordon levitt's inception
character arthur is tasked with keeping
watch over his helpless comrades in much
of the same way that his dark knight
rises character blake protects the
innocent kids of gotham city tom hardy's
bane meanwhile picks up where his
inception character eames leaves off
using masks and ultra violence to
achieve his ends and marion coach yards
miranda and mal are each so devoted to
their convictions that they don't
hesitate to sacrifice themselves for
what they believe in the end of
inception didn't just affect nolan's
movies either raking in over 825 million
dollars worldwide while also garnering
massive critical acclaim inception paved
the way for a whole wave of high concept
big budget sci-fi fare including films
like looper source code the adjustment
bureau limitless
in time edge of tomorrow and lucy and
then there's marvel's doctor strange
which unapologetically lifted
inception's entire city bending sequence
however the most obvious and annoying
influence of inception may be this
created by composer hans zimmer to give
potency to several action sequences this
obnoxious noise has been featured in
seemingly every sci-fi blockbuster since
inception
and zimmer hates it he told vulture oh
it's horrible this is a perfect example
of where it all goes wrong that music
became the blueprint for all action
movies really and if you get too many
imitations even i get confused so
all we can say is
enter the dream ever since inception's
debut fans have been clamoring for a
sequel but while nolan has publicly
toyed with the idea of a video game that
allows players to explore the world of
inception so far nothing has come of it
still there's hope that someday fans may
be able to play through inception
themselves and figure out firsthand just
what the ending means to
them district 9 is an uncommonly smart
sci-fi hit and it's got a heck of a lot
going on especially in the final act did
you come away wondering what really
happened or museum on what could happen
next not to worry this is the ending of
district 9 explained
when most films end audiences are
treated to powerful soft light shots of
the hero kissing their love interest
hugging their relatives or celebrating
their great victory over the antagonists
but district 9 has no clear-cut heroic
ending in fact given how much of the
story revolves around bikus vondermarva
slowly succumbing to a horrible disease
if you're not paying close attention to
the ending you may end up wondering is
vikkas even alive is he lying in a ditch
somewhere did the nigerian mercenaries
finally eat his body from magical powers
well don't worry vikas is very much
alive at the conclusion of the film
unfortunately he's also very much an
alien we know this because vikus's wife
finds a metal flower made out of trash
left on her front doorstep which she
believes may have come from him the very
next shot is an alien making another
flower so either vikus's wife has a
secret admirer amongst the prong
community or vickus himself is leaving
her small tokens to let her know he's
okay common sense would suggest it's
probably the latter
it's pretty clear that vickos becomes a
full-on alien by the end of district 9
and you'd be forgiven for wondering if
there's any scrap of humanity left in
him at all throughout the film vica
slowly loses control of himself and acts
in increasingly strange alien ways
that said the flower vikus leaves his
wife is as good an indication as any
that bika still clings to at least some
of his humanity earlier in the film
vicki's wife explains that he loves
making her fun craft projects it seems
that alien vikka still feels that urge
to let his wife know he's generally
doing okay and hasn't fully lost his
personality even if he's a little
slimier than the last time she saw him
if you look closely at vikas
post-transformation it's also clear that
one of his eyes retains its blue human
color while the other is green like
those of the other prawns this would
indicate that there's still a small
portion of vikkus which remains human
and retains at least some of his
previous memories he's certainly more
prone than man but that doesn't mean
he's lost all of his humanity
at the end of district 9 the prawn named
christopher who fights alongside vikus
throughout the film ultimately escapes
the planet thanks to vikkis's sacrifice
and assistance christopher is able to
get his damaged command module working
and fly himself and his son up to the
recently activated mothership of course
one question remains how long will it be
before christopher is able to return to
earth he promised to cure vicus of his
illness after all how long will vickus
be forced to wait earlier in the film
christopher convinces vikkas to help him
by assuring him he can reverse vikka's
slowly worsening disease but after
learning about the government's
experimentation on his people
christopher tells vikas he needs to
alert his people to what's happening
before he can dedicate the necessary
time and alien fuel needed to heal
vickus christopher estimates it'll take
him three years to make the trip to and
from his home planet back to earth so
christopher will return but it's more
than likely that vickis will be forced
to live as a prawn for at least three
years until then
speaking of those human on prawn
experiments just how excited do we think
alien high command will be about
christopher's story even without all the
brutal torture and experimentation
aliens have been treated as second-class
citizens abused and manipulated by
citizens of earth for nearly three
decades we don't know much about alien
culture but we do know they have some
hugely impressive technology including
powerful guns and exoskeleton power
suits it's hard to imagine they don't
have a military of some sort and who
knows what other crazy weapons or bombs
they might have on their home planet
vickus may have slightly softened
christopher's opinion of humans but
christopher is still clearly upset about
what's happened to his people either way
there's surely no way to explain what's
going on in district 9 that won't
antagonize the prawn leadership and if
the aliens return with any sort of
retribution on their mind humanity is
probably completely screwed
one of the largest unanswered questions
at district 9 is just why the alien fuel
actually turns humans into prawns it's
clear vicki's transformation starts when
the fluid is sprayed into his face but
nobody ever figures out exactly why
things go the way they do even weirder
christopher doesn't seem at all confused
when vicus transforms he immediately
knows the fluid would do that and seems
highly confident that the medical
machines on the mothership could heal
vickus are you saying that you can you
could turn this this this brawn hand
enter into a human hand i mean you can
make me human again
interestingly it also appears that alien
fuel plays some role in healing humans
because christopher says he needs all
the available fuel to travel quickly
which is why it'll take a while to heal
vicus the fuel brings up all kinds of
possible implications for the future of
the district 9 universe for example
could other humans accidentally become
prawns is there more alien technology
containing the fuel out there amongst
the trash heaps is it possible the
prawns themselves could weaponize the
fuel in such a way as to transform all
of humanity lots of future scenarios
could play out on earth thanks to that
fluid and most of them don't exactly
bode well for humanity
the cloverfield paradox has a relatively
simple plot a space station crew is
tasked with activating a particle
accelerator called the shepard which
will create a clean and renewable source
of energy for a resource deprived earth
things start to get complicated however
when the machine creates a rift in
space-time propelling the crew into a
parallel dimension little do they know
this also sets into motion the events of
the first and second cloverfield movies
so how does the movie get from a simple
energy experiment story to an all-out
monster invasion movie let's walk
through the last bits of the cloverfield
paradox and break it down
monster madness
cloverfield fans have long speculated
about where the monsters from the first
movie came from but paradox finally
offers a definitive answer they came
from another dimension oddly enough we
find this out thanks to an on-screen
interview with the conspiracy theorist
who warns the world that launching the
shepherd could have devastating
consequences
they risk ripping open the membrane of
space-time this experiment could unleash
chaos his words are unfortunately
ignored of course but he's ultimately
proven right once an overload of the
shepherd system thrusts the crew into an
alternate reality while introducing
untold numbers of hell beasts to run
roughshod over earth the film's closing
moments reveal that by 2028 there's been
a full-on invasion of monsters all over
the planet you're having to come back to
these things judging from the size of
the one we do see pop through the clouds
in the last shot if there's a
significant number of these things
roaming about the place humans don't
stand a chance
world war what
before the extra dimensional chaos
breaks out it's very clear that
earthlings are already having a lot of
trouble sustaining their way of life a
global energy crisis has put several
nations germany and russia in particular
at the brink of war and that sense of
desperation and paranoia trickles into
the dynamics of the international space
station's crew which features both a
german and a russian scientist working
on different aspects of the mission tony
woman 18
but your little german boyfriend over
here i do once we journey with the crew
to the parallel dimension we discover
that on that earth war has already
broken out and that timeline schmidt
actually was a german agent who'd been
sabotaging their mission to stoke the
flames of war so chances are even if the
monsters hadn't shown up the human race
might have gone over the edge all by
itself anyway
the god particle
like its franchise predecessor 10
cloverfield lane the cloverfield paradox
was written as an entirely separate
project at first lane was based on a
script called the cellar while paradox
was developed as the god particle for
reasons that aren't altogether clear
from the movie itself
in scientific terms a god particle is a
name for what is properly called a higgs
boson a particle effectively responsible
for the origin of mass they're also
theorized to have the ability to overlap
and occupy the same points in space-time
unlike other particles like electrons or
protons in theory god particles may have
played a part in the fictional function
of the shepherd particle accelerator in
earlier cuts of the film or perhaps it
just served as a cool title to a weird
sci-fi movie that dabbled in particle
physics but either way there aren't any
god particles in the cloverfield paradox
so it's a good thing they changed the
name
one world saved it's easy to chalk up
the efforts of the film's protagonist to
a zero-sum game they go through all of
the effort to get back to their home
dimension and figure out how to make the
particle accelerator work only to
realize as soon as they do that earth is
now facing a problem the accelerator
can't fix it's a bitter twist but there
is one silver lining the crew does save
earth it's just not their earth right
before activating the accelerator and
heading back to their earth during the
film's climax hamilton and schmidt send
the schematics for the shepard particle
accelerator to the parallel earth the
one at war over energy resources it
might take some time but this planet now
has the means to access clean renewable
energy and save itself hopefully without
inviting a bunch of massive monsters
into this dimension
10 cloverfield lane tells a small story
designed to stand on its own but it's
also deceptively full of complex plot
twists potent but understated themes and
a few hidden ties to a larger
cloverfield mythology let's unlock this
bunker of secrets and explain the ending
of 10 cloverfield lane
though they seem to have nothing in
common on the surface a look back at
cloverfield may provide some clues about
the aims of 10 cloverfield lane the
original movie is about a giant
monster's arrival in new york city but
that's just a backdrop to the main drama
through its found footage conceit
cloverfield showcases a group of
20-somethings sending off their friend
rob as he prepares to move to japan to
start a new job cloverfield's invented
first person angle on a classic godzilla
formula makes it an effective thrill
ride but it's the naturalistic depiction
of young adults in 2008 america that
gives it a surprising amount of weight
in short it's a giant sci-fi blockbuster
interrupting an intimate indie drama
about people struggling with regret
their perspectives are shaken and shaped
by unimaginable horror making their real
needs clear for the first time that
brings us to the sequel
10 cloverfield lane introduces us to a
heroine in a hurry in the opening
sequence michelle is anxiously packing a
suitcase her eyes darting to the stormy
horizon outside is she desperate to
escape a monster invasion as it turns
out she's fleeing from an ill-fated
proposal and ignoring calls from her
boyfriend leaving behind an engagement
ring and taking a bottle of whiskey she
hits the highway out of new orleans in
the midst of the drama that will soon
follow it might be easy to lose track of
just how much is being set up about
michelle's character here the fashion
sketches seen strewn around her
apartment the radio news reports about
massive blackouts and even the bottle of
whiskey are all elements that will pay
off later most importantly we learn from
her boyfriend's call that she has an
apparent chronic problem with commitment
it's clear that his words strike a chord
with her as she grows increasingly
distracted listening to his voice from
behind the wheel we had an argument
couples fight that is no reason to just
leave everything behind running away
isn't gonna help
so distracted in fact that she's
unprepared for the truck that sideswipes
her into a violent wreck
michelle wakes up in a strange
cinderblock room that's half gray and
half painted pink and some sort of sad
attempt at cheery femininity she's
hooked up to an iv drip and her leg
injured in the crash is in a brace but
the brace is chained to the wall someone
has saved her life but is also holding
her captive that someone is howard
stambler howard soon explains that he's
taken michelle into his private
underground bunker in the aftermath of
some sort of attack he's fuzzy on the
details muttering theories about
everything from russians to martians
howard has known for years that
something was coming though and has been
preparing for this day michelle's room
we gradually learn was supposed to be
for his daughter megan why isn't megan
here instead according to howard her
mother turned her against him it's an
explanation couched in the disturbingly
familiar language of abuse
before she can come to any conclusions
about whether or not she trusts howard
michelle becomes aware of a third person
in their midst emmett is a young man who
helped build howard's bunker and made
his way to it as soon as loud sounds and
lights in the sky signalled the
onslaught of whatever invasion has
occurred friendly and naive emmett
quickly becomes michelle's ally in
solving the bunker's mysteries it may
not be immediately clear but emmett
serves a few functions in the story his
most obvious purpose is to give michelle
support and someone to talk to as she
navigates her situation he also provides
some important exposition informing
michelle that howard was always known
for his doomsday prepper mentality and
eventually sharing an important
revelation about a photo that howard
claims is of his daughter megan most
ominously it's significant that howard
seems to barely tolerate emmett's
presence
howard's consistent irritation toward
emmett suggests that he has more
specific goals with the bunker than
saving lives
unsurprisingly michelle remains hesitant
to trust the man who chained her to a
wall and told her martians may have
attacked she remains not entirely
convinced by his stories even after he
brings her to the bunker's heavy locked
door to show her a pair of mutilated
pigs outside as evidence of what the air
itself will do to anyone who breathes it
so at the first opportunity she bashes
him in the head grabs his keys and makes
a break for the door but before she can
open it she's met by a woman begging to
be let in screaming and desperate as the
skin seemingly melts from her face fully
convinced that the air outside is indeed
dangerous michelle resigns herself to
remaining in the bunker the decision is
made easier by a seemingly softened
attitude from howard who talks her
through the process of stitching up the
head injuries she caused while sharing
stories about his time in the navy they
soon enough move on from the disturbing
death they've witnessed but the memory
lingers over the film until the very end
as the only two people who can relate to
each other michelle and emmett naturally
end up sharing stories about their lives
before the bunker they talk about
tattoos they've always wanted with
emmett saying that he would have gotten
plenty if he had known the attack was
going to happen when asked if he has any
regrets howard replies
everything i wanted to do i did
i focused on being prepared
and i was
and here we are later after the
occurrence with the woman at the door
emmett tries to comfort michelle by
assuring her that there was nothing she
could have done to help this brings up
more talk of regrets michelle is haunted
by the time she saw a little girl being
abused by her father and did nothing to
help while emmett's life was changed
when a lack of confidence stopped him
from getting on a bus to start college
at louisiana tech
michelle and emmett settle in for life
with howard though the piece remains
uneasy in a particularly uncomfortable
game night howard fails to associate the
word woman with michelle struggling with
words like girl and princess it's a
disturbing indication of how much she's
infantilized her the tension comes to a
head when michelle tasked with crawling
through the bunker's vents to fix an air
filter discovers a window to the outside
into which someone has scratched the
word help nearby she finds a bloody
earring which she recognizes from
howard's photo of megan but when she
shows the picture to emmett he
recognizes the girl not as megan but as
a classmate of his sisters who
disappeared from the area some time back
regardless of how correct he might be
about the dangers outside it's now clear
to michelle and emmett how dangerous
howard is he's been using the bunker to
hold young women captive in a deluded
attempt to replace his daughter and
michelle is next
michelle has a plan she envisions a
makeshift hazmat suit envisioned from
the bunker's shower curtain and various
household items she and emmett begin
assembling the materials while availing
howard's notice unfortunately it doesn't
work for long and howard calls the two
of them up to help him move a barrel
inside the barrel is an acid capable of
dissolving human bodies down to the bone
howard makes it clear that he knows that
michelle and emmett are up to something
and that if they don't confess they'll
end up in the barrel emmett accepts all
responsibility for the plan and howard
accepts his apology by calmly shooting
him in the head howard insists to a
shocked michelle that like everything
else he's done this to protect her soon
after he undergoes some sort of bizarre
dad transformation appearing
clean-shaven and neatly dressed for the
first time as he offers michelle ice
cream the uneasy tension of his demeanor
has been replaced by an even more
terrifying sense of total unchallenged
delusion but michelle's real call to
action comes in a silent scene that
finds her going through emmett's
belongings and finding the bus tickets
to louisiana tech he's been holding on
to for all these years her resolve is
bolstered with the uncertainty of the
world outside leaving the bunker is less
about saving her own life than it is
about not letting regret define her
death
the film's climax kicks off when howard
discovers michelle's nearly complete
hazmat suit and she narrowly escapes his
wrath by momentarily trapping him in her
room when he breaks free and corners her
near the perchloric acid she has no
choice but to push a barrel over
starting a fire as soon as the acid hits
an electrical outlet fleeing through the
vents from a burned and furious howard
michelle uses the can of liquid nitrogen
to break the exit's massive padlock and
at last escape this final flight out of
the bunker is fast and intense but a
careful retracing of the movie's plot
reveals just how much of it has been set
up all along michelle has successfully
constructed a hazmat suit thanks to her
interest in fashion design that's part
of her character from the very beginning
her knowledge of the ventilation layout
is established by the earlier filter
repair sequence one of the film's most
intense moments in its own right and the
liquid nitrogen trick was subtly
foreshadowed by howard's casual aside
about doing the same thing in the navy
michelle has spent her time in captivity
learning everything she needed to
survive
in the open air of howard's farm
michelle briefly panics when a hole
tears in her suit but the sight of birds
flocking overhead unharmed tips her off
that the air may not be as toxic as she
believed sure enough she removes her
makeshift plastic bottle face mask and
can breathe without trouble but then a
horn sounds nearby alerting her to the
presence of an enormous alien craft
sailing over the crops as darkness falls
another ship rises up from behind the
house and an enormous tentacled beast
emerges michelle takes shelter in
howard's truck and though the creature
lifts it up and nearly devours her she
has one more trick up her sleeve and
it's yet another plot point set up in
the movie's earliest scenes with a
bottle of whiskey she took with her when
she left home she fashions a molotov
cocktail that not only burns the alien
but causes a chain reaction with the
gases in its body obliterating the
monster in a huge explosion
the most important reason for 10
cloverfield lane's surprising final
sequence though is to bring michelle's
character arc to a significant final
moment she commandeers the car left
behind by the woman at the bunker's door
at first following radio instructions
for survivors to gather at baton rouge
her escape is interrupted by another
radio message
if you have any medical training
or combat experience
we need help
silently reflecting on how everything
that's happened to her has given her
exactly the necessary skills she turns
toward houston as stormy skies reveal
more ships looming in the distance the
movie ends on this moment of decision
with our heroine barreling toward danger
it's far more than an open-ended sequel
setup however it's the first time
michelle is committed to facing a
problem head on instead of running from
danger or difficulty we've watched her
go from a scared uncertain person racked
with regret to a decisive competent hero
ready to give herself over to a noble
cause everything about her time in the
bunker her battle with howard and her
honesty with emmett has brought her to
this place
terminator dark fate has arrived and
it's safe to say that fans have a lot of
questions which works out really well
because we happen to have a lot of
answers answers that require spoilers of
course with that warning let's break
down the ending of terminator dark fate
the first two thirds of terminator dark
fate set the table a new evil terminator
model called the rev9 has been sent from
the future to kill a mexican woman named
daniela luckily someone also sent back a
bionic woman from the future named grace
to protect her along with sarah connor
looking to get revenge after her son
john was killed by a terminator they end
up finding help from a very unlikely
source arnold schwarzenegger's t-800 who
has been stuck in the past since killing
jon after the events of terminator 2.
the real surprise here though is that
this terminator has voluntarily given up
the terminating business and has settled
down in a human life under the name carl
he embodies the core message from t2
that people can choose their own fate
and rewrite their future he decided to
stop being an evil killing machine and
instead become a nurturing father figure
it's an unexpected twist that suggests
humans and robots may actually be able
to live together in peace after all if
the robots simply choose a different
path
one of the big mysteries in terminator
dark fate is just why the robots have
sent their agent back in time to kill
dany during the final chase scene though
grace reveals the truth that dany
herself actually becomes the resistance
leader in the future as sarah puts it
she's the new john connor the last best
hope for all mankind
like carl danny's character arc also
reinforces the idea that you can choose
your own fate
several times in the film the others
urge her to run and hide but she instead
insists on fighting back she chooses to
become the hero humanity needs and
indeed it's those choices that actually
make her a hero it's a real contrast to
john who often seemed to reject the role
of savior only reluctantly being pressed
into it by circumstance jon as a
character seemed consigned by fate while
dany chooses her own path i want to
stand and fight
the last third of terminator dark fate
is essentially one giant never-ending
action sequence that involves car chases
helicopters multiple plane crashes gun
fights and a humvee getting swept over a
dam leading to an underwater brawl it's
such a whirlwind of non-stop excitement
that you may not have noticed it's all
very very familiar basically every
action beat in terminator dark fate is
based off of something from a previous
terminator installment in a way that's
thematically appropriate even though
sarah successfully destroyed skynet and
t2 which should have led to a happy
future we learn instead that skynet was
just replaced by a new ai called legion
the details of the future are different
but the outline is still the same just
as the details of dark fate are
different from the previous films but
the plot is still the same the message
now seems to be the opposite of t2 in
dark fate no matter what you do nothing
ever really changes your destiny
in the climax of the film the whole team
of good guys faces off against the rev9
which seems unfair until you consider
the rev 9 has the ability to split into
two different self-sufficient robots a
metal exoskeleton like the t-800 and a
fluid form like the t-1000 the only way
the good guys are able to win is by
grace sacrificing herself so dany can
take grace's power source and jam it
into rev9's eye hole causing it to melt
down as it happens fans have seen this
before because that's almost exactly how
arnold's good guy terminator defeated
the evil tx in terminator 3. he removes
his power core and shoves it in the tx's
mouth where upon it explodes and
destroys both of them we're not sure if
this is a loving homage to terminator 3
or if they just assumed everyone had
forgotten terminator 3 existed at all
either could be true
with the power core delivered to the
rev9's head there's just one last thing
that needs to happen a sad descent into
the pit where both the villainous rev9
and the heroic t-800 model known as carl
blink their final blinky lights it's sad
or at least it's supposed to be sad
because it's very intentionally calling
back memories of the infamous ending of
t2
you remember that one right it's the one
with the thumbs up it's obvious director
tim miller is hoping the memory of t2's
tear jerker ending will add some much
needed gravitas to the climax of
terminator dark fate
avengers end game isn't the only action
movie this year that gets its emotional
resonance from the films that came
before i love you
that's not the final moving moment
designed to play on people's emotions
though the final scene of terminator
dark fate is designed to deliver a
double subliminal whammy to anyone who
has seen terminator and t2
dany and sarah connor are at a
playground where they watch a young and
oblivious grace playing with her family
after dany vows to make sure grace
doesn't have to sacrifice herself she
and sarah jump in a waiting vehicle and
drive off to prepare for the impending
armageddon the playground element of
course is a clear reference to the
infamous playground scene in t2 where
sarah connor watches families get
incinerated by the skynet caused nuclear
holocaust and the riding into the sunset
ending is exactly the same as the end of
the first terminator film only this time
instead of being pregnant with the
future savior of humanity that she has
to train sarah connor is riding shotgun
with her
structurally terminator dark fate is
almost identical to the original
terminator film in much the same way
that star wars episode vii the force
awakens is the soft reboot of the
original star wars episode iv a new hope
so we actually have a pretty good idea
where they could go with the next film
in the series a new version of t2 sure
the plot would actually have to be
different but the main thrust of t2 was
the attempt to prevent armageddon by
destroying skynet in dark fate they
don't ever have the chance to even think
about stopping the apocalypse but they
could certainly try to take steps in
terminator 7 to prevent the new ai
legion from coming to be one thing is
for sure we can't wait to find out which
beloved scenes from the previous
terminator films they'll remake in the
next one
when the netflix original film the
platform dropped in february 2020 the
spanish horror thriller quickly
generated a ton of buzz for its unique
dystopian setting and the prescient
symbolism at the core of the narrative
at first glance the film appears to be a
story of individual greed and the
struggle to survive but as the movie
reaches its haunting conclusion it
becomes clear that there's something
deeper going on at the outset of the
platform we're introduced to goring a
new inmate in a vertical prison at the
top a team of chefs prepare a lavish
feast big enough to feed everyone in the
hundreds of cells below and each day the
titular platform containing the food is
lowered the platform stops at each cell
for two minutes and the two prisoners in
that cell can eat as much or as little
as they want of course those at the top
get their fill while those at the bottom
are left with nothing and end up
starving the catch is that the prisoners
are assigned a new cell each month
rearranging the pecking order in
relation to the platform the ambiguous
sending of the platform and the film's
metaphorical nature throughout have left
many viewers trying to figure out what
it all means let's run through the
symbolism of the movie and what message
the filmmakers wanted us to take away
from the final moment we get bits of
details about what the purpose of the
prison is throughout but it's not until
goring meets emma geary who works for
the prison herself before becoming an
inmate that we get a more concrete idea
emma geary tells goring that the
administration prefers to refer to the
pit-like prison as a vertical
self-management center or vsc she
explains that in order for the food to
reach all the way down to the lowest
levels there needs to be a spontaneous
sense of solidarity meaning everyone
without communicating to one another
only takes as much as they need she
seems to imply that the whole purpose of
the prison is to create a system in
which people can learn to foster this
spontaneous sense of solidarity however
goring proposes a more sinister
interpretation
if that solidarity emerged they would
know how to avoid it from happening
outside wouldn't they
according to goring's interpretation of
the prison it's a small-scale model of a
harsh capitalist system that the ruling
class is using to test the responses of
the proletariat it's a tool for the
rulers not society as a whole most of
the main characters we meet in the
platform represent archetypes or ideas
larger than themselves for instance
goring who volunteers to enter the pit
in order to obtain a college diploma
represents an idealistic intellectual at
the beginning of the film he shames the
greed of those who take more than their
share when they have the opportunity but
doesn't understand why they do it as he
has yet to spend a month at the bottom
of the pit similarly emma geary
represents a willfully ignorant
bureaucrat upon which a system like the
vsc rely in order to function when
amigiri enters the pit it's revealed
that she's mostly in the dark as to what
exactly happens in there like goring she
attempts to convince the prisoners below
her to ration their food but they don't
listen to her please perhaps the most
enigmatic character in the platform is
maharu a beauty woman who rides the
platform each month in search of her
young child maharu is disdained by the
fellow prisoners and is often attacked
even emigiary derives a struggle
claiming that her search for her child
is a lie because nobody under 16 is
allowed in the pit maharu represents
those who suffer from the periphery of
society whose stories we don't want to
believe because they sound so cruel that
we can't imagine that we live in the
same system for instance people
experiencing homelessness or other forms
of extreme poverty at the end of the
film we learn that maharu's child is
real and has been living at the very
bottom of the pit goring arrives there
after riding the platform down with a
weapon enforcing the rationing of the
food by beating and killing anyone who
tries to take more than their share his
plan is to return back to the top level
with an uneaten dessert a symbol that
the prisoners have learned how to work
together to survive in such a way
however after finding the child goring
realizes that that isn't the message he
needs to send the discovery of maharu's
child is confirmation of the most
important component of the vsc
experiment those in power set the rules
but they clearly don't follow them
themselves although they've assured
everyone they would never do something
as cruel as allow a child into such a
horrendous existence that was a lie the
conclusion of the platform sees goring
sending the child back up on the
platform as a message to the chefs at
the top who are presumably in a similar
state of ignorance as emma geary instead
of proving to them that the prisoners
can adapt to the system he wants to show
them that the system itself is
unspeakably and unfathomably cruel and
those operating it cannot be trusted
adastra sends brad pitt to the far
reaches of space on a quest for his
father the truth and the sense of deeper
meaning if you're wondering what it all
adds up to let's break down the ending
and major takeaways of adastra after
spacecom determines that clifford
mcbride is likely behind the destructive
antimatter pulse that kicks off the
movie's plot his son royce dispatched on
a mission to mars in an effort to
establish communication with the elder
mcbride roy ends up journeying all the
way to neptune where he discovers that
spacecon was right his father is still
alive and was at least partly
responsible for the anti-matter surge a
surge came after the crew of his station
staged a deadly mutiny irrevocably
damaging the battery powering the
station but the true tragedy at least in
clifford's eyes is the result of all
their research which shows no sign of
intelligent alien life in the universe
although the lima project compiled reams
of data about outlying planets and
systems it didn't find what clifford was
really looking for clifford was so
determined to find new life that he was
willing to abandon his family and even
kill for it although the information he
did gather is valuable for him it's not
enough roy mcbride is uniquely qualified
for the mission to determine the fate of
project lima there's his family
connection to the project's long-lost
leader and the fact that he is like neil
armstrong was described to be an almost
supernaturally reserved man even working
in dangerous conditions in deep space
his pulse goes no higher than 80 bpm and
he deals with the bad news about his
father with a steely calm
now we're counting on you to help us
find him
are you with us
yes i am sir
it's this quality that comes in extra
handy when roy realizes what space com
is really up to specifically the agency
is out there that will cross him and
kill clifford the secret plan or the
longest to observe roy's attempt to
establish communication with clifford
using clifford's response to figure out
where he is and then travel there to
finish him off with a nuclear weapon
once he figures it out roy proves more
than a match for the other team
successfully sabotaging their mission
before journeying to neptune in peace
the central message of adastro is best
summed up by roy's words to his father
just before they leave project lima roy
tells his father that what cliff has
proven that there's no alien life to be
found it's just as important as finding
another world full of intelligence by
learning there is no intelligent life in
the known universe cliff has shown us
that as roy puts it we're all we've got
speaking to digital spy writer director
james gray explained that the idea of
looking for answers in alien life isn't
a particularly appealing idea to him
grace said the idea that there's these
little green men out there that'll
either save us or eat us to me that's
more horrifying than having to rely on
other people
with the lima project's antimatter
battery damaged the station is a lost
course actively endangering life on
other planets as it breaks down clifford
can't repair it but thankfully roy has
arrived with a solution of sorts the
nuclear bomb spacecom intended to use on
clifford after getting his father out to
the station roy uses the bomb for part
of its intended purpose blowing up the
station and getting rid of the battery
it's an ignominious end for lima project
which set out on a hopeful mission
before spiraling into madness violence
and catastrophic loss of life clifford
ran away from earth hoping to find
answers but ended up creating more
problems underlining one of the movie's
major themes running away from problems
or meant to face head-on can only lead
to disappointment
somewhere between earth and neptune it
seems pretty obvious that cliff mcbride
has lost his freaking mind but one of
the interesting things about that astro
is that with roy's voyage we get to
follow in cliff's footsteps and see
exactly how his marble spilled out roy's
narration tells us there are physical
strains affecting his mental health like
the extended time spent in zero gravity
there's also the crushing isolation of
space something roy commits to facing as
he continues on his quest to find his
father going past the moon past mars and
then all the way to neptune
are you ready
i'm ready
roy's journey mirrors what must have
been his father's in a lot of ways
including the death toll when roy
reaches his father we learn the
antimatter surges aren't something cliff
has been causing on purpose his
struggles against his crew he says
caused the damage that led to the
antimatter instability this is something
roy is familiar with because his trick
through the stars has left its own trail
of collateral damage with few exceptions
just about everyone who has been at
roy's side throughout his journey is
dead by the end of the movie though he
doesn't mean for it to happen he
indirectly causes the death of the
surviving crew on the ship to neptune
just as cliffon directly unleashes the
antimatter surge that threatens the
solar system
after they escape project lima cliff
detaches himself from roy guaranteeing
his own certain death he has more than a
few reasons for doing it first there are
the consequences you might have to face
upon returning to earth he doesn't know
that his crimes have been swept under
the rug and so has no reason to think
he'll be shown any mercy second while he
may refuse to admit it to himself what
he calls his destiny has proven to be a
sham considering everything he's done
for that destiny how could he not want
to end things finally as he tells roy
this lonely void has become his home he
has no desire to return to earth that
astra has been compared to a number of
classic movies from the ore and wonder
of 2001 a space odyssey the character
study of first man and the grounded
thrills of gravity it's also drawn
comparisons to apocalypse now in the way
way has drawn deeper and deeper into
space on his dangerous quest but at
astra is fundamentally about the desire
for connection between parents and their
offspring and between people in general
and the dark places people can be driven
to when that connection is lost
it's a very human story dealing with our
connection to humanity in many ways roy
mcbride's journey is a terribly sad one
he's betrayed by his employers and faced
with the reality of his father's crimes
potential insanity and then death
he loses the parent he journeyed
billions of miles to save but in spite
of that loss the movie's message remains
hopeful as roy tells clifford we're all
we've got and those bonds are strong
enough to take us all to neptune and
back
[Music]
[Applause]
denim villenos sci-fi drama rival hit
theaters in 2016 and earn rave reviews
from critics thanks to amy adams
brilliant performance vilneb's excellent
direction and a mature focused take on
the alien invasion genre but that
doesn't mean it isn't confusing in fact
a rival's focus on linguistics and
space-time theory is tough to untangle
and only seems to get more complex the
deeper you dive into it but we've got
you covered if you're ready to dig deep
and don't mind spoilers here's
everything you need to know about
arrival's confusing ending the sapir
wharf hypothesis
if you want to understand this complex
film first you need to wrap your head
around the linguistic theory at the
center of it which holds that our
perception of reality is either altered
or determined by the language we speak
an example of the hypothesis in action
the hungarian word for raccoon an animal
that doesn't exist in central europe
outside of television and zoos is moso
medved which literally translates to
washing bear the idea is that
hungarian's colorful term for raccoons
also affects their perception of the
creature itself so that they can see and
understand it differently than those of
us who just call a raccoon a raccoon or
a trash panda
rewiring louise's brain so the sapir
wharf hypothesis states that our reality
is determined by our language in arrival
that argument is pushed to its outer
limits dr lees banks is the one who
first begins to truly learn and
comprehend the heptapod's strange
non-linear mode of communication thus
she's also the first to perceive reality
space and time the same way the aliens
do the total overhaul of louise's
reality begins shortly after she teaches
the heptapods her and ian's names while
dissecting some printouts of the alien
language she has this vision of her
daughter playing with a caterpillar in a
field a moment easily dismissed as a
random memory of the daughter she lost
but these flashbacks intensify and
appear more frequently as she learns
more of the heptapod's language leading
to a bombshell moment in which what seem
like memories are now revealed to be
visions of louise's future i don't
understand
who's this child
weapon opens time
dr bank's job is to find out why the
heptapods came to earth leading to a
global international crisis when the
heptapods say that they're here to quote
give weapon but what louise realizes is
that the aliens don't really mean weapon
they mean tool and the tool they intend
to give humanity is their language which
will come in handy three thousand years
from now when the heptapods face
extinction and need humanity's help
since people who speak heptapod
experience time in non-linear form
they're capable of drawing on
experiences from anywhere within their
own existence to make choices and change
events that's how louise is able to
flash forward 18 months to the gala
where she encounters chinese general
shang who tells her what she said to him
to stop him from starting a war of the
worlds in the present and since sheng
has learned to speak heptapod himself in
those intervening months he also
perceives time non-linearly so he knows
that what he tells louise in his
timeline will be useful to her past self
confused let russ cole help you out we
see
our face down would look flattened
heptapod time is like that beer can a
flat circle and on a flat circle cause
and effect can happen in any direction
what luis says to shang leads him to
speak to her at the gala but what shang
says to louise at the gala also leads
her to say what she said and that makes
perfect sense as long as you accept one
more hypothesis
everything is predetermined
needless to say louise returns from her
mental flash forward to make the phone
call that saves the world and everyone
lives happily or tragically ever after
but what if she simply chose not to
that's the bad news she can't choose
now you know
in order for that future conversation at
the gala to happen and it does luis has
to follow through on the phone call this
is the other big difference between
linear and non-linear time in linear
time you can make choices that alter the
shape of your future you might be able
to move in only one direction but every
choice you make represents a fork in the
road in non-linear time life is a
circular track in which you can travel
either backward or forwards but there's
no branching off the existence of free
will is fundamentally incompatible with
a non-linear experience of time which is
also the heart of a rival speaking
heptapod gives louise the ability to see
the future but shatters her illusions of
ever being able to change it
moonfall is a movie about the moon
collapsing onto earth and that's the
simple part we haven't even gotten to
the swarm of ai robots yet
[Music]
[Applause]
it's on airplane mode
moonfall begins when a routine space
mission goes awry with two astronauts
brian harper and joe fowler barely
surviving what brian can only describe
as an attack from an unidentified source
joe having been unconscious assumes the
assault was some kind of solar flare the
disagreement leaves the colleagues and
friends estranged with brian becoming a
washed up deadbeat to his only son sunny
while joe moves up the nasa ladder ten
years later a conspiracy theorist named
kc discovers that the moon has been
knocked off its orbital path and is on a
collision course with earth he winds up
teaming up with the two former friends
to figure out how to correct the moon's
course but they both balk at his theory
that the moon isn't what it seems they
begin to grow more sympathetic to his
crackpot theories when joe is promoted
to head of nasa and given clearance to
see the original footage from her and
brian's botched mission there she meets
a mysterious book named holdenfield who
explains he's been responsible for
covering up the truth about the moon
since earth's earliest expeditions joe
starts to come around to the craziness
when she witnesses with her own eyes the
phenomenon that brian tried to get her
to believe a heart-stopping swarm of
black nano machines she surmises that
whatever this entity is its presence is
what set the moon out of alignment if
earth is to be saved it needs to be
dealt with but even though nasa's top
brass have been aware of the moon not
being what it seemed for decades they
don't know its true nature all they know
is that whatever it is it's more
advanced than humanity can handle
initially in response to the moon threat
joe had scrambled an emergency mission
with the help of some european allies
the intent of the mission was to see
what's inside the 26 kilometer deep
crater on the moon that the black swarm
had come out of but that mission killed
everyone involved so plan b has to be a
little more drastic
with no faith or support from the rest
of the government and very little
resources at their disposal joe has to
bring in brian who encountered the
entity before and kc whose status as a
megastructurist might prove useful
especially now that she knows most of
the accepted knowledge surrounding the
moon is completely useless the new plan
is to get a lander onto the moon's
surface equipped with a super powerful
emp the military had been developing for
years to deal with nasa's secret moon
problem the project had been abandoned
is too costly but one working prototype
still exists which is what ends up being
used in an attempt to destroy the black
swarm as the moon's gravitational pull
and exponential velocity increases the
plan starts to look impossible to pull
off the one usable rocket loses one of
its engines the moon itself begins to
fall apart as it gets closer to earth's
atmosphere sending debris all across the
landscape but the gravity tsunami that
the moon brings with it proves to be
useful in getting a rocket out of orbit
even without the engine thrust necessary
to get the rocket to properly launch
unfortunately this scientific revelation
comes after everyone working for nasa
has been released to go home and find
shelter with their loved ones leaving
the film's three leads to embark on this
insane mission alone
with the original plan b already looking
like a failure the military-industrial
complex gets hard at work on a much more
logical solution to this absurd problem
they're going to nuke the moon this adds
extra pressure onto joe and brian's
mission as they're stranded out in space
unsure of whether their cowboy maneuvers
will even work and if they do they have
no way to communicate with the military
to stop them from nuking the moon to
smithereens but joe does have one
contact on the inside as her ex-husband
doug is with the joint chiefs in the
colorado doomsday bunker joe was
supposed to bring their son to compared
to joe and brian doug is a
straightforward guy who isn't exactly
thrilled at the nuke the moon plan but
in the absence of better more concrete
plans sees it as humanity's only chance
to keep from having the moon hitting
everyone's eyes like a big pizza pie if
only he had some way to know that his
ex-wife's long-shot plan of getting a
rocket into space actually worked
luckily brian's son sunny alongside joe
and doug's young son saw the rocket take
off they've been driving to the doomsday
bunker themselves running into all
manner of apparel but joe's son has a
satellite phone with a direct line to
his dad so they're able to notify doug
that the mission is acted if he pulls
the trigger on launching all those nukes
he'll be pulling the trigger on dooming
his son to grow up without a mother this
leads to a standoff between doug and
every other authority figure in the
bunker right at the moment they're meant
to begin the launch sequence to initiate
to nuclear onslaught on the moon it's a
crazy bit of drama because doug doesn't
understand joe's plan how it's going or
if it's even feasible all he knows is
that joe has never let him down before
but the plan is essentially screwed
ryan's initial idea is to lure the black
swarm out by exploiting its reaction to
electricity before destroying it with
the emp but it sees through their ruse
when it tries to destroy the ship they
realize it's not solely electricity that
the swarm responds to but rather organic
matter alongside machinery with no other
recourse brian pilots the lander into
the deep crater the swarm is retreated
into and that's where the real fun
begins
you know we are just inside the moon
that might be the greatest sentence
anyone's ever said
the inside of the moon is as casey had
theorized a megastructure an enormous
vessel crafted by advanced alien life he
says some in his community believe that
all megastructures are arcs but what
they discover next proves he's only half
right as the swarm tries to destroy them
there is another opposing force within
the moon's core one that takes over the
controls of the ship and guides them to
safety on the other side of a blast door
an area they discover that has air
when casey and joe wake from the crash
they discover brian is missing and go
exploring this newfound space but brian
is already communing with an entity that
possesses all the answers it speaks to
him in the guise of his son but it's the
operating system for the super machine
that is the moon it's a mega structure
but it wasn't created by aliens it was
made by humans as told to brian the moon
is an art created by a form of the human
race that was far more advanced than
ourselves they had created a utopian
society and proliferated throughout the
cosmos but one day the artificial
intelligence they had created to help
run this society grew sentient turned on
them and vowed to destroy all of
humanity they created moons to find
suitable places to build new planets to
be seated with human life our earth is
only one successful settlement created
from the moon and seated with human dna
the moon orbits the earth to protect it
should the ai swarm ever find it as it
has now the operating system tries to
understand why brian is so willing to
risk his life to save the rest of the
planet and his answer about love for his
own son and for his race lets the moon
know he's ready to get back into the
game and stop the ai it supercharges
their ship gives brian what can only be
described as temporary superpowers and
sets him out to get into a dogfight at
the moon's core with a malevolent swarm
of human hating nano machines the
ensuing laser battle culminates in the
realization that one of them is going to
have to stay behind in the lander to
detonate the emp and put a stop to the
swarm for good ryan has decided to
sacrifice himself but someone else has
other plans
casey a man who has spent his whole life
having his scientific beliefs treated
like a joke who no i never thought would
amount to anything has finally gotten to
see space and see his research and
life's work validated casey has in the
last few days of the film's narrative
live more of an exciting life than he
previously had in all his prior years
combined that's why he can't let brian
or joe stay behind when they have
children on earth that need them ryan
must go back now as the main conduit to
the moon's deep reservoir of knowledge
regarding humanity's secret history
casey is going to stay behind and
culminate the unlikely journey he
embarked upon in the film's introduction
he sacrifices himself defeating the
swarm and making it possible for brian
and joe to reunite with their families
on earth his sacrifice doesn't seem to
be permanent as the film closes casey
re-materializes in the same space brian
learned about the moon's true origins
only now the operating system presents
itself as casey's mother and his cat
fuzz aldrin it explains that his
consciousness has been uploaded into the
moon's supercomputer and that his work
is far from over
the matrix resurrections is a movie
about making the matrix resurrections we
cannot emphasize this enough am i crazy
we don't use that word in here the end
of resurrections begins with a much
anticipated sit down between neo and the
analyst their venue for this meetup is
the delightfully named simulate coffee
shop where thomas anderson has received
much of his stimulation over the years
and inspiration via a beautiful woman
named tiffany who bears a striking
resemblance to our old friend trinity
this tiffany has a lot invested in the
world she sees every day she has a
husband a job three children but also a
persistent feeling there must be more as
well as a relentless affection for
ducati motorcycles at the coffee shop
neo and the analyst finally lay all
their cards on the table and decide to
let her break the stalemate if tiffany
decides to stay tiffany neal will return
to the matrix once and for all and
become thomas anderson again if she
decides to become trinity all bets are
off the architect who says he likes
tests accepts saying we'll let tiff
decide breaking down the stakes the
grown-up sati sums up neo's dilemma with
a single line the most important choice
in neil's life
it's not his demand
after watching moss's character
essentially being lobotomized for most
of the film what comes next is
particularly satisfying as her husband
and kids make one last sales pitch it
appears that tiffany might return home
with them just as neo is being dragged
away however she delivers four words
that trigger the film's ending and
perhaps more matrix movies to come my
name is trinity
one of the more welcomed upgrades and
the matrix resurrections is the new
agent smith although hugo weaving was
nothing short of iconic in his work
originating the character jonathan groff
does a fine job as his new face at the
end of revolutions it looked as if both
neo and smith have been destroyed with
resurrections we once again see that
smith and neo's fates are tied to each
other as his boss becomes his enemy
graff's smith takes over in the key
matrix role of engaging neo in multiple
high-powered memorable smackdowns by the
end of the film it looks as if smith
might have been eradicated but when neo
and trinity need saving smith once again
returns from the dead this time to fight
on their side he substantially aids
their efforts in the simulate coffee
shop then vanishing once again he points
out to our heroes anyone could be you
whereas i've always been anyone
what follows is all the butt kicking
bullet dodging aerial acrobatic
choreography you would expect from a
matrix film this time with neo and
trinity backed up by a new crew led by
bugs as the group make their way out of
the simulate the analyst turns the
matrix against these viruses threatening
his creation in essence every human in
the area turns into a quasi-zombie
attempting to take down the heroes when
trinity shows up on a ducati and has
neo-hop on board this sequence gets
particularly striking as in hundreds of
bodies striking the streets down below
diving out skyscraper windows and
essentially turning themselves into
bombs attempting to hit trinity and neo
as they speed through the streets after
many close calls explosions and
imperiled colleagues trinity and neo
make it to their destination but what
comes next if people are truly to be
freed the analyst himself must be
confronted but with neo and trinity
united again and their minds freed
anything is possible
with that bit of business concluded and
agents closing in neo and trinity take
to the roof of a skyscraper where they
take a great leap of faith throughout
the matrix resurrections neo keeps
seeing the same recurring image of birds
in flight flying in some sort of time
loop we are also told that thomas
anderson tried to step off the roof of a
building at a corporate party but was
pulled back at the last moment an event
witnessed by bugs finally it becomes a
sort of running joke throughout
resurrections that people ask neo
whether he can still fly and he can't
make it happen all this builds to neo
and trinity literally taking a leap of
faith stepping off the top of the
building holding hands at first they
begin to fall and you'd be forgiven if
you just assume neo's old skills will
kick in and he'll save the day instead
it's trinity who discovers an ability to
fly reminiscent of neo soaring away at
the end of the original matrix this time
it's trinity who takes to the sky with
neo along for the ride
when the duo confront the analyst
together this time in his office the
power dynamic has shifted considerably
now instead of dictating the terms to
neo surrounded by dozens of his agents
he is on his heels and alone but that
doesn't stop the analyst from bragging
about his plans waxing philosophic about
the intrinsic shortcomings of mankind
and telling the duo time and again that
their efforts are useless as if to drive
home the point that he's the one
fighting the losing battle trinity kills
the analyst again and again each time
with him snapping back until he finally
seems to admit defeat at this point the
analyst seems to shift from saying
they'll never gain control to
essentially saying they'll hate the
burden of having control what are they
gonna do he asks rebuild everything with
rainbows in the skies as he puts it the
sheeple aren't going anywhere at this
point the newly reunited trinity and neo
resolve to do exactly that joking that
the rainbow idea actually sounds pretty
nice
if you stick around through the credits
you'll notice that when the title the
matrix resurrections is flashed on the
screen it becomes the matrix resurrects
could this be the title of the next
potential film like the end of the
original film the final moments are
soundtracked by the uplifting rebellion
rock of wake up only this time rather
than the ferocious rage against the
machine original the cover version you
hear is by a band called brass against
with help from sophia urista
unfortunately the post-credits scene is
a real disappointment when the titles
lift and the screen lights up again we
are transported back to thomas
anderson's old place of work where his
team are still debating new marketing
ideas and ways to make money off the
matrix franchise as in the earlier
scenes it's all very meta someone says
face reality movies are dead games are
dead narrative is dead their solution
create programming for felines a series
of videos called the catricks and yeah
that's real
dune titled on screen as dune part 1
covers roughly the first half of frank
herbert's book ending on something less
than a cliffhanger until part 2 arrives
let's talk about where dune leaves off
and how we got there in the first place
in a far flung future deep in space the
planet arrakis is the center of an
intergalactic empire due to its natural
resource spice a sought-after substance
integral to interstellar travel when the
film begins that planet and its spice
mining industry is lorded over by house
harkonnen and their sadistic head baron
harkonnen but the emperor gives this
prestigious station to house atreides
led by duke leto leading their entire
family to move from their home planet
kaladan but when they arrive on arrakis
leto discovers that the entire operation
has been internally sabotaged the fremen
arrakis's native inhabitants still seek
to overthrow the imperial power
structure that oppresses them the
machinery necessary to mine spice
effectively all lies in various states
of disrepair and of course the
harkonnens left behind an assassin
entrenched in the palace walls to make
an attempt on the life of letto's son
paul the only promising element of
lettuce plans for the new planet under
his charge is in his hopes to form an
alliance with the fremen but fate has
other plans
baron harkonnen in collusion with the
powerful religious and political
sisterhood known as the benny jesuit and
the emperor himself hires the sartikar
the emperor's elite fighting force to
attack house treaties the sadakar attack
under the cover of knight with the
harkonnen's forces led by glasuruben
bottlenecking them from the other end
the baron also kidnaps the wife of
leto's doctor wellington uh in an effort
to blackmail him into helping with this
coup the duke and dr yue are killed by
the baron and dr ue's last ditch attempt
to kill the baron only leaves the latter
wounded but before this dr ue also helps
lettuce and paul and paul's mother lady
jessica to escape the carnage but they
are captured by the harkonnens anyway
they are not however killed as a
complication from baron's alliance with
benny gesterat jessica part of the
sisterhood herself and her son who they
have plans for are to be spared but the
harkonnens hope to abandon them in the
middle of the desert knowing there's no
way for them to reasonably survive its
harsh terrain lady jessica and paul are
able to escape their grasp but still
find themselves stranded with only a
pair of still suits to keep them alive
in the heat of arrakis as they struggle
to find shelter for the night jessica
and paul have to reckon with the visions
he has been seeing throughout the film
paul has been secretly raised through
his training to be a mythical chosen one
a powerful being prophesized by the
sisterhood's lore as director denis
villeneuve said
everything around paulie's future has
been constructed by a woman he's
basically unwillingly a years-long
eugenics experiment with nascent
superpowers destined to rule the
universe one day meanwhile in the
present day paul and jessica reunite
with duncan idaho paul's mentor and
friend who has miraculously survived the
attacks he helps them get away in search
of a fremen sect to recoup and
strategize with once there they meet up
with dr lee atkins the ecologist
assigned by the emperor to oversee the
regime change from harkonnen to atreides
dr kinds knows that something pernicious
is afoot but can't get more involved
than absolutely necessary ultimately
pledging fealty to the fremen and
neither imperial external force paul has
to accept that he is the head of house
atreides now and pledges to see through
his father's plans for the fremen
thinking he can work with them under the
promise of freeing them from the empire
but the harkonnens have other plans
the harkonnens descend on this temporary
hiding place ready to finish the job on
the fremen and the remaining atreides
survivors but duncan idaho locks jessica
paul and dr kinds behind a stronghold
door intending to fend off the wolves at
the gate by himself to save them
throughout the film duncan has been his
one true friend now paul must run away
yet again with his mother and dr kinds
as duncan fights alone
duncan can i trust you something yes
always you know that
duncan goes one versus many on the
invading hordes taking out plenty of men
before succumbing to mortal wounds with
no remaining friendlies on arrakis and
no other options paul and jessica have
to soldier on in the desert hoping to
find fremen who may or may not be
sympathetic to their cause jessica and
paul encounter stilgar's sack to fremen
who initially see them as little more
than bodies of moisture to covet stilgar
and james are both in favor of just
killing them and taking the water from
their bodies but stilgar remembering his
meeting with leto sees some merit in
sparing paul's life he just doesn't see
that same merit in saving jessica's
tensions rise to a boil when moves are
made to harm jessica who gets the upper
hand on silgar leading to a standoff
where paul finally meets chani she's the
same woman he's been seeing in his
visions this entire time but jameis
can't leave this infraction alone by
besting their leader in combat jameis
has to challenge jessica to retain true
control over their sect so he challenges
her to fight with paul having to step in
as her champion paul's visions have
seemingly been building to this moment
paul and jameis fight with jameis
clearly the more ruthless combatant at
multiple points paul has jameis dead to
rights just like in the fencing style
sparring sessions he has with bernie
haleck in the film's first act but this
is no duel the only way to win is to
kill which paul finally does this marks
paul crossing over into his destiny
finally abandoning his youth with all
the tragedies that have brought him to
this moment jessica wants stillgard to
help them get off world but paul sees
that their future lies here with the
fremen
as paul jessica and the fremen traverse
the desert on the way back to their
stronghold he continues to be plagued by
visions he sees his eyes glowing blue
like johnny like the rest of the fremen
and sees himself leading a fremen force
in a war against the rest of the empire
my road leads into the desert
i can see it
whether we will actually see the other
side of this epic tale of paul's arc
from boyhood prodigy to reluctant
messiah remains to be seen
total recall is one of the most beloved
science fiction films of the last few
decades and its ambiguous ascending has
led audiences to wonder was quaid
dreaming or was he actually a secret
agent here's the ending of total recall
explain
one of the most important facts of the
movie is that the plot of total recall
identically mirrors the memory implants
that doug quaid himself requests from
the recall organization quade asked for
the secret agent package
i don't want to spoil it for you doug
but you rest assured by the time the
trip is over you get the girl kill the
bad guys and save the entire planet
coincidentally quaint realizes he was
always a secret agent gets the girl
kills the bad guy and saves mars quaid
appears to wake up before the implant is
actually inserted but the salesman is
very specific about the realism of the
implants and how they trick the brain
into thinking it's remembering real
memories is quaid dreaming or just
remembering his true self the blurring
of reality and dream continues
throughout the movie with multiple
villainous characters begging him to
question what he believes to be the
truth surprisingly the villains are 100
correct quaid is streaming and the
moment the camera cuts away from the
start of the recall procedure everything
that follows is our visual impression of
quaid's dream in fact many of the
movie's plot elements are called
directly from innocuous moments embedded
in those few opening scenes the recall
employees even say that they combine the
base program with elements from the
subject's real life to better create
realistic memories
the movie opens with a dream as quaid
sees himself and the woman will later
learn as molina on mars in spacesuits
quade slips and falls down a hill and
his helmet breaks his eyes bulging out
of his skull as he wakes up ending the
dream at the end of the film equator
molina are sucked out into the
atmosphere of mars and his eyes bulge
out of his skull in almost the same way
the recoil scientists are using quade's
dreams for potent imagery the better to
match his subconscious desires with his
recall and planted memories even if
quade is actually hauser on a deep
secret mission it makes no sense for him
to dream his own death in a way that
looks identical to what actually happens
quaid streaming death scene is
foreshadowing for the final action set
piece on mars a viscerally effective
image that the scientists used to make
the recall sequence feel even more real
this aft overlooked detail is one of the
strongest pieces i've ever done that
quaid is streaming in the opening scenes
prior to the recall procedure he walks
through an x-ray machine we see his
skeleton move through the box without
alerting anyone of any hidden metals on
his body later after the recall
procedure has begun and quaid is running
for his life he passes through the x-ray
machine again this time setting off an
alarm as it recognizes the gun he's
holding however attentive viewers
remember that quade actually has a
tracking chip buried in his cranium that
he then has to remove to cast off his
pursuers the tracking chip is clearly
made of metal but didn't appear in the
x-ray either before or after the recall
procedure why not because quaid hadn't
yet gotten to that moment in his dream
the scientists used the memory of his
stroll through the machine as an action
set piece but because quaid didn't know
at the time he had a tracking chip his
subconscious mind didn't bother to
change the imagery of his skeleton
early in the film one of quaid's
co-workers from the construction company
wants him to not go to recall he heard
someone was almost lobotomized there
friend of mine tried one of their
special offers nearly got himself
lobotomized quaid ignores this warning
after the recall procedure he discovers
that his former friend is actually an
undercover agent for the government
tasked to keep quaid unaware but is he
his warning about the possibility of a
lobotomy echoes throughout the visual
inspirations of the movie when craig
pulls out his tracker chip he pushes a
tour through his nasal cavity until he
hears a crunch a strikingly similar
process to original lobotomy procedures
likewise when a doctor shows up on mars
to tell quade he's having an adverse
reaction to the recall procedure he
takes attack of reminding quaint of the
possible side effects to the brain when
cohegan is planning to swap quade's
memories with houses the terror of the
scene is that quai's personality will be
erased a terror shared by similar horror
stories of lobotomies even quaids
eyebulging near death scene at the end
of the movie can be read as the fear of
a brain aneurysm the dangers of the
recoil procedure reverberate through the
entire film
when quaint is discussing the recall
procedure with the salesman bob mclean
mclean mentions their special package
this process involves taking on a new
identity and quaid bristles against it
he still wants to be him but he's
tempted by the secret agent option he
eventually takes it once mclean gives
him the hard sell but his initial
discomfort of being someone else becomes
sublimated into the recall procedure
quaid as we find out later in the film
is also hauser a secret agent and one of
kohagan's right-hand men quaid has to
struggle against being re-implanted with
hauser's personality perfectly mirroring
his own discomfort with the recall
procedures multiple identities option
quade wanted to remain true to himself
while still taking advantage of the
secret agent module of the recall
procedure and that manifests in his
battle with the hauser personality
hauser allows him to be both a secret
agent deep undercover while still
remaining the same person he was before
being woke up from that deep cover
molina is a mysterious woman who first
appears in quaid stream that opens a
film she's given no dialogue or
personality just a face in an astronaut
suit later when quaid goes to recall
they ask him to describe his perfect
woman encouraging him to be as honest as
possible to have more fun in the
implanted memories quaid describes a
woman who is quote brunette athletic
sleazy and demure and before he passes
out he sees that the scientists are
sculpting molina's face we know from the
beginning that the scientists are
combing through quade's dreams to better
fit him for an implant while molina's
face appearing on the television could
be interpreted as quaid hallucination we
know it to be a product of the scientist
technology molina herself as we later
find out works in a brothel is athletic
and is both demure and sleazy she
perfectly matches the personality type
quaint wants to appear in his recall
memories
laurie quade's wife is against recall
and mars altogether when quaid is
enacting his secret agent fantasy he
imagines her as a mole for cohegan that
he positions her as a villain when she's
so against him wasting money on a
dangerous procedure or a vacation to a
war zone makes perfect sense her
convenient secret marriage to koh
hagan's lieutenant richter allows kwei
to freely pursue molina without having
to worry about any sort of guilt for
breaking his marriage vows as an added
bonus she consistently compliments his
masculinity and sexual prowess even when
she's an enemy quade can't help but use
her to prop up his own ego
while the sales agent boasts equate that
recall implants are better than a
regular vacation he lists a litany of
annoyances that their service avoids you
got lost luggage lousy weather crooked
taxi drivers
when you travel with recall
everything
is perfect when craig is on mars later
in the film he gets a ride from the
ultimate crooked taxi driver benny a
cabbie who has a deal with a specific
establishment that gives him a cut of
the profits if he brings tourists there
but that's not all later in the film
benny is revealed as a double agent for
cohegan tasked with discovering the
secret mutant freedom fighter's lair
benny's presence serves as a bomb for
quaid's word mind if this were a real
recall procedure then there wouldn't be
any crooked cabbies just like maclean
explained earlier in the film by the
time quaid reaches mars his mind has
started to protect him from the
possibility that the recall procedure is
going very wrong
laurie shows up again when quaid is
confronted by dr edgmar who warns quaid
he's in danger of suffering a schizoid
embolism and he's trapped within the
dream he says he and laurie the real
actual mrs quaid have gone into quaids
fantasy to pull him out before further
damage occurs he warns quaid that the
recoil fantasy will become so jumbled
that the quote walls of reality will
break down one minute you'll be the
savior of the rebel cause and the next
thing you know you'll be kohagan's bosom
buddy you'll even have fantasies about
alien civilization edgemar continues to
say that if this fantasy continues quaid
will be lobotomized back on earth quaint
thinks edgemar is a plant and shoots
them both but the doctor is right the
walls of reality and the hotel literally
break down as kohagan's men burst in
shortly after the mutant leader quatto
is murdered leaving quaid as the leader
of the rebellion just as cohagen bursts
in to deliver the news that quaid is
actually hauser his right-hand man the
doctor's prediction was exactly right
as the scientists are preparing quaid
for the recall procedure and the
beginning of the film one of them
notices something odd in quade's dreams
he tells the other lab worker
ernie
that's a new one blue sky on mars he's
referring to the blue sky that ends the
film just as quaint wonders if he's
actually dreaming and he is the
scientists have never heard of a blue
sky on mars before they put quaid under
and their acknowledgement of its
significance is what allows them to
create a soothing ending for quaid's
recoil dream
likewise in the lab scene the secret
alien arc reactor can be spotted
flashing across the screen before
quade's put under one of the scientists
also makes the observation that quote
it's all about alien artifacts these
days it makes no sense for the recoil
officers to actually have access to the
alien artifacts that koh hagan is
obsessed with keeping to himself it
appears on the monitor because it's part
of quaid streaming package and they're
prepping the operation director paul
verhoeven himself backed that up on the
dvd commentary saying all the images of
the tubes that you just saw are of
course the tubes that you see at the end
of the movie when the nuclear reactor
starts
but if all of that evidence can't
convince you that maybe the director's
words will paul verhoeven lays out the
clues that point to the dream
interpretation on the dvd commentary of
the movie starting at the moment that
quai drifts off to sleep after seeing
molina's face on the monitor be aware
that if everything that happens in the
movie from now on is going to be a dream
if there is no reality to anything
realize that the dream really starts at
the moment that he falls asleep so the
next scene which seems to be a [ __ ] up
of the machine is part of the dream the
hovind continues so this is the last
moment of his reality goes into the
unconsciousness and basically from now
on boom the dream starts that's the
trick of the company that they make a
dream that's so convincing that it
seamlessly goes from the first reality
into the second one check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you